Sports Illustrated is laying off most of
its staff the brand is going under we
got a cultural episode for you today
mostly because there's just basically no
news but this is pretty big news because
Sports Illustrated is a legacy brand
it's been around since 19 I think it was
it 1954 and now they're done and there's
an argument over what caused them to
collapse so we've got an AI Scandal and
we also have a scandal involving two
instances where they put transgender
models on the cover of their swimsuit
additions and a lot of people are uh not
too happy about that now the argument is
did they get woke and go broke or were
they going broke so they did a hail Mar
to try and save themselves by getting
woke I got to be honest it it it sounds
like if that's the case your boat is
sinking so you decide the best way to
stop your boat from sinking is to punch
holes in the bottom of it and then it
just sinks faster but perhaps that is
the case we'll talk about that Alec
Baldwin is being uh criminally charged
involuntary manslaughter so we'll talk
about that and then of course we do have
uh uh we got some political stuff to
talk about it's Friday we're chilling
slow news day we're going to have fun
with it and just talk about these
cultural issues so before we get started
my friends head over to cast brew.com
and buy coffee we got the new Alex
Stein's Prime Time grind two times
caffeine available now but drink respond
responsibly Folks at caffeinees no joke
everyone's favorite I got to tell you
you have to buy Appalachian nights right
now you got to go to cast brew.com buy
appalachin night's ground coffee maybe
just some coffee pods and give it a try
because uh while I genuinely believe
it's the best coffee I ever had it's
easy for me because I'm the one who
actually blended it we get sent all the
origins all the different kinds of
coffee I'm like here are the kind of
flavors I like I mix them together I'm
like this is my kind of cup of coffee
and now our sales are through the roof
rise with Roberto Jr used to be the top
seller but all of of a sudden
Appalachian Knights is selling like 10
times faster than all the other ones and
I'm actually getting worried cuz we got
to sell more coffee we can't just sell
one kind but uh check it out you'll
really love it and when you buy Casper
coffee you support the show plus our
coffee shop is underway and the
paperwork by which we will be expanding
is also underway and uh we want to have
coffee shops all over the country also
head over to
timcast.net to the membersonly Discord
we are actually planning membersonly
events and the first notification of
those will be only two members in the
Discord so uh I will give you a heads up
with our new cast Brew building in
Martinsburg West Virginia it is very
likely that we will have periodic if not
once a month maybe live membersonly
shows and the tickets will be announced
only through the Discord so if you do
want to come out come hang out if you're
in the area we're really excited to uh
uh to have you but you got to join the
Discord server you got to become a
member and help support all of our
endeavors because everything we're doing
with like these caucus shows and these
uh in-person events massively expensive
and we could use your support to do it
so smash that like button subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends joining us tonight to talk about
this and everything else is Alx Hi how
are you good who are you I am the
executive producer of the Benny show and
I'm a Creator on x.com oh very simple
right on well thanks for hanging out we
got Phil leonti hello every my name is
Phil leonti I'm the lead singer of All
That Remains I'm a very failed musician
anti-communist and counterrevolutionary
congratulations on all your
multiplatinum failures or gold your gold
failure multi plaum on the walls and
it's it's Benny Johnson you're who you
produced for people don't know the Benny
show it's good check it out uh I was on
this I'm Ian crosson on the uh what is
it the the culture War earlier today
with dude it was Ben Davidson um who
suspicious observers on YouTube that was
and Jimmy coretti yeah from Bright
insight and we talked about pole shifts
I mean wild just I mean the electric
Universe I feel like is a very real
Theory and we kind of went deep I I just
got to say anybody who like watches Tim
cast IRL and they're like it's it's too
blackpilled like I'm going to watch
something else do not watch the show we
did this morning where basically this
guy is like the the planet is going to
tilt 90° night will become day oceans
will boil and you will all die he didn't
say it like that I'm kidding but he was
basically like get prepared you have 10
years Nothing Else Matters and I was
like wow yeah that was kind of a part of
the feel of it as interesting as the
technology was that was a feeling like
yo there's going to be a pole shift and
we got to prepare for it he he was
saying that the the Earth will tilt 90
degrees because these these pole ships
happen periodically there's evidence of
these things and so that's what he
believes and uh he was like I think we
have maybe like 10 or so years it's not
going to be as apocalyptic as that it's
just there's going to be rapid economic
shifts which people need to PR prepare
for but check that out uh on uh YouTube
tenet media the culture War podcast and
uh where all podcasts are found very hot
yeah also got my man to the right here
yo I am surge.com it's pleasure to see
you Alex Alx I uh saw you at I think am
fest and I could only say hey for like
one second so you guys the live show on
the stage those yeah yeah yeah right uh
anyways yeah let's get jump into the big
news today Sports Illustrated lays off
most of its staff after AI Scandal and
money troubles its parent company has
fired more than 100 employees it's kind
of wild to see that apparently their
their parent company missed a payment
for the rights to use the the brand and
now the company is laying off tons of
people they've owned the magazines in
2019 sold the publishing rights I'm
sorry ABG owned the rights to uh they
sold the rights to Arena Group which is
amassed substantial debt and missed a
recent $3.75 million payment for the
rights and this is the end you know what
man it's kind of sad but also my my
question is should we be happy about it
right Bud Light is on the verge of death
they're saying there's going to be a
strike potentially in March there will
be no beer because the employees are
upset they want more money budlight
can't give them more money because
nobody's buying budlight and you know
what's really fascinating we actually we
we on this show discussed this the
understanding that uh the Cascade
failure effect of a major brand budlight
may make a billion dollars you stop
buying budlight and what happens is the
cost per can goes up so uh let's let's
start from the very beginning we have a
cast Brew Coffee we sell and whole bean
coffee we wanted to sell cans of cold
brew to sell at the volume we can afford
it would cost $5 per can to have a can
of cast Brew cold brew coffee that no
one's going to buy that I mean that's a
ridiculous thing to like buy a can of
coffee for five bucks you need to get
down to like $2 or you know $220 which
means if we were to sell maybe like 2
million cans then we would make I don't
know 10 grand off that sale and that's
enough profit generated to cover the
cost of all the employees if we lost
$50,000 in sales of 2 million cans now
we are not breaking even anymore the
whole thing just collapses that's what's
happening to Bud Light when I see Bud
Light failing everybody's cheering but
part of me is like hey maybe this is
what the woke left wants Sports
Illustrated gets woke goes broke and now
we're all like haha you get what you
deserve for all I the woke left is like
we've destroyed a legacy brand there was
there was a dad who handed a Sports
Illustrated to his kid it's talking
about football and his favorite like
look this is when so and so first got on
the team it was something I remember now
it's like what are what are you going to
remember from your childhood that you're
going to be able to hand down I don't
think we should be celebrating these
Legacy Brands getting woken blowing up
no because it's like it's it's a culture
Revolution this ideology is parasitic
and it will destroy whatever it takes
over if it it will take it'll you know
infest it or it'll invade it'll take
over it'll wear whatever it takes over
like a skin suit and if it destroys it
totally it's fine it does it's
completely completely it's completely
fine with
destroying uh whatever it is that it
gets into whether it be uh you know
video games or whether it be you know uh
the sports or or whatever it doesn't
matter what it is whether religion the
the whole Liberation the ology all that
stuff is all Marxist influence and stuff
it'll get into
whatever it is that you're whatever you
know uh institution you're talking about
and then it'll either assimilate it or
it'll destroy it everybody's cheering
for the destruction of Bud Light because
Bud Light did the Dylan Mia thing and
I'm like okay totally get it but
understand I mean when was bu when was
Bud Light budweis has been around for a
really really long time someone want to
Google when Bud Light came out I don't
think we I I think we should celebrate
when we defeat wokeness but I think we
have to be careful if we C celebrate how
the woke sabotaged and destroyed 1982
was Bud Budweiser Light and then
reintroduced 84 as Bud Light so I don't
I don't care too much about budlight in
that con like it's been around since the
80s okay fine but with Sports
Illustrated and with other Publications
I think I think it would be important
for us to recognize if the the the the
goal of Wess in the culture Revolution
may be we don't care if we own it or
it's destroyed so long as we own it or
it's destroyed exactly 100% that's
that's that is the entire goal of the of
the cultural revolution they need to
take over what the things that Americans
come together over so whether it be like
whether it be budlight as a brand or you
look at what they do to Disney Disney
was a wholesome family American brand
and now Disney's reeling with half the
country hating Disney and half the
country loving Disney and and there's
all kinds of strife that's that kind of
stuff is what this ideology does it
can't do anything but the the it can't
do anything but destroy the whole thing
is called constructing they got us
cheering for the destruction of our
institutions yes that's terrifying we
should not do that we should not destroy
things and that's why like we talked
about about whether or not we should
like you know make room for people that
realized that that they had you know
been consumed by bad ideas whether woke
or whatever you want to call it and you
have to make way make a space for people
to come back in you have to make it okay
for people to come back be like yeah I
think maybe I was kind of wrong on that
stuff you can't mock them you can't make
fun of them you can't you know be like
no and shun them and stuff because we
it's it's an illiberal ideology that's
infected them if they want to move
beyond that and come back to Liberal
principled stances then we should we
should welcome them yeah I think um one
of the goals of this ideolog assume that
it's like a communist attempt to disrupt
would be to get half of like your
friends to turn on you and be like no
you're not woke enough you got to be
woke and then 5 years later they come
back and they're like I'm sorry but then
for you to not forgive them would be a
victory for the this communist thing
like you've got to forgive these people
when they realize that they were played
yeah it's I mean I think it's weird
though how like the AI thing like how
how long ago was that that that story
came out was a couple months ago I don't
know anything about it what is it so a
bunch of uh journalists uh they were
fake journalists like they'd have fake
profile pictures and fake names or
whatever and they were just like you
know they' you'd read the article and it
would make no sense they're all AI
generated articles and they'd publish it
as if they were real journalists on the
site and then like somebody you know ran
it through an AI Checker and also like
could clearly see that these weren't
real people and stuff and you know
published a piece on it this is Sports
Illustrated yeah oh yeah and then like I
think that was a couple months ago and
then so it it seems in here that like
they didn't you you know pay the
licensing fee or whatever so it's kind
of weird how like you know that came
right after that if it was kind of
planned like uh to do that like to take
down the brand or I'm not sure but it's
it's like certainly weird that those two
events you know coincided like they
couldn't afford to pay writers so they
used AI then they couldn't afford to pay
licensing so they just didn't that's
possible that the brand I never really
understood Sports Illustrated as a brand
or as a product and I remember in the
80s and 90s like it was a magazine about
sports but I had TV at that point so
like watching pictures of a dude like
this is in no way exciting watching a
guy throw the ball that's cool and you
may be sitting in the back of a car or
on a plane or a train or waiting in a
Lobby and like it was like it was about
reading like sports stats I guess but
then when the internet came out because
they they would they would like go and
like have journalists like sit down with
like the people that were theyd s you
sit down with coaches and players and
owners of teams and all that all of the
inside stuff you were getting with
Sports Illustrated it wasn't just like
hey these guys beat these guys on this
day you know it was like all the stuff
that goes into it you and then the
internet came out and was like the great
leveling and uh it just became one of
like a thousand periodicals that do that
kind of thing and I remember the Sports
Illustrated uh swimsuit issue was always
a big deal that's like the only time
every year anyone we even talk about
Sports Illustrated in my crew we weren't
like huge athletes um I I think it's
inevitable that uh periodicals the
people that rely on print I don't know
if Sports illustrators still relies on
print or if they have an online
subscription model but these things are
all the way of the dodo they're extinct
they they've gone Obsolete and maybe if
if the power all goes out and we're back
to like trading cards in the dark then
maybe books and novels and magazines
will become relevant again but when you
can check it all for free on the
internet these things have no place
anymore they need to adapt their their
business model it sounds like this
company didn't do that I don't know if
they even I mean I assume Sports
Illustrated had a website I mean I
haven't gone to look but um yeah yeah I
think it was like the online version um
of the sports Illustrated stuff that was
all yeah I'm looking at it now it's
futurism I think was the publication uh
they had like this guy Drew Hernandez as
the or Drew Hernandez Drew Ortiz as the
author no we like Drew I know right as
the author's biography it say Drew has
spent much of his life outdoors and is
excited to guide you through his
never-ending list of the best products
to keep you from falling The Perils of
nature it read uh nowadays there is
rarely a weekend that goes down goes by
where Drew is not out camping hiking or
just back on his parents Farm all this
likeand because he was not a real person
yeah and like the the profile picture is
just some like AI generated like person
and these are like the biographies of
stuff and then they reached out and uh
Sports Illustrated deleted like all of
the Articles and stuff we were talking
last night about uh the Galaxy s24 I'm
not going to buy it by the way I bought
it you did I bought it um well I want I
want to see what it's all about I want
to see the extent to which reality is
being ripped from our from our
faces dude it's going to be cra crazy we
we we are we are walking ourselves into
the Matrix one step at a time for those
that didn't hear what we were talking
about the the new Galaxy and and to to
an extent even the iPhone can do this
you'll take a picture like let's say Ian
takes a selfie of himself standing like
you know on the on a like on the
Michigan Beach Navy Pier Chicago he
takes a picture of himself by the feris
wheel then he looks at it and he goes
I'm kind of off-centered so then he
clicks the magic AI button Taps himself
moves it turns on a little and he twists
the rotates the image then press fix it
will generate the missing portions of
the photo creating fake images what we
are what we are now going to start
seeing popping up all over the Internet
photos of people and we thought it was
bad enough that you've got like mid
journey and stable diffusion people are
going to take a picture on their phone
and it's going to be a fabricated
circumstance everything we see online
will be fake yeah and then eventually
why bother actually going anywhere we're
inching ourselves to the point where
someone will be like because first of
all people have already done this where
they put post they post fake Photoshop
pictures of themselves like traveling
the world and stuff because it makes
money now you've got fake AI girlfriends
being posted by dudes to make money off
lonely guys and stupid guys why bother
going to India at all at this point when
you can just take a picture of yourself
on your Galaxy tap it and it puts you in
in in India it's what's the and you can
like use VR to actually tour places in
India like with in like actual virtual
tours you can go in the pyramids with a
virtual tour walk around and see all the
walls and read the hieroglyphs and stuff
you're going to go on Instagram and
you're going to see your buddy he's
going to post a picture of himself
standing by the water like giving a
giving a wave and he never did that
before he's going to be like well I was
I was actually like 30 feet away and we
were leaving I I I snapped a quick pick
but I just moved it so it looked like I
was there cuz I was there all fake
reality yo 10 years ago this is longer
than 10 this like 13 years ago I was at
uh uh in Chicago not too far from Navy
Pier and there was a presentation being
given by this group talking about how
soon all news articles would be written
by AI they already had the technology at
the time and they explained it's
actually really simple to uh uh create
the language to describe the temperature
and the weather and what they plan for
it so if they have the data that says
like it's going to snow at 4 p.m. when
you look at hourly weather data and it's
like sunny at 2 cloudy at 3: snowing at
4: all they have to do is plug that into
an AI that will say this morning we'll
experience fair weather where at 2 it
will still be sunny however an hour
after that we expect to see clouds
followed by snow AI generating all of it
we are now well past that point where
Sports illustrator was running totally
AI generated articles with a guy they
claimed was real and I assure you a lot
of other Publications are doing the
exact same thing one thing that I'm I'm
very curious over I don't quite
understand News Guard requires
organizations to have biographies for
their staff but some of these big public
the major ones they won't put a by line
it'll say just like by staff yeah and
I'm talking like ABC and things like
this you'll be like who wrote this where
did this come from Yo the machine it's a
matrix bro the computer is is the funny
thing is like when you watch The Matrix
we assume that it's going to be like
this omniscient sentient hive mind of
machine kind being like humans tried to
destroy us so we fought back and reality
it's going to be like all we're doing is
repeating back to you what you said to
us yeah there's going to be no emotion
no intent it's going to be a garbled
mess of psychotic nonsense so so look at
it this way right now when you go to
like mid journey and you type in like
hey generate me an an image of you know
Rockstar singing a song it will make
that it's basing it off of real photos
of rockstars but as people generate AI
images and then post them to the
internet labeling it Rockstar singing
the AI will then eat the AI generated
image incorporating the AI generated
image into its model it's like a game of
telephone yeah with itself it's going to
spin like a tornado constantly cycling
its own data through itself here's what
you do take a picture put in a copier
and then just keep copying the same
image over and over and over again and
see what happens get like faded and
weird looking it's going to turn into a
bunch of speckled garbled nonsense
that's where we're going with AI but the
problem is we are handing AI the
controls to all of our systems and our
economics and
so you thought it was when Jack dorsy
hooked the toilet to his own throat and
started Garling the diarrhea that he had
produced imagine what it's going to be
like when you do it with AI Jack dorsy
walks away and the AI is spraying you in
the face with all of it oh my gosh
welcome to the Future man The Matrix is
not some fun Journey it's going to be
weird dude man I part of me is like yo
I'd love to play nine video games at
once like plug my brain and so I can
enjoy all this all this data but the
other part is like I want to go to South
America I can see the farm where I live
with the tree line I can see the the the
pineapples growing like and and just
live that life off not necessarily Off
the Grid but like not in the grid my
first experience with like mid journey I
was like typing like Republican
protesters versus Democrat or democrat
versus Republican and each time the like
the Democrat one they always had like
satanic horns and like it's super
creepy yeah it's like this is the IM did
did you guys ever see the rejected
Cartoons by Don herzfeld no no my spoon
is too big you don't know maybe yeah of
course so when I'm thinking about what's
going to happen I'm reminded of like
two-thirds in here it it says Don's
clear and steady downhill State
continued soon he was completing
commercial segments entirely with his
left hand and it's like this oh wait we
got to get the audio going is it
[Music]
good
so the monkey por Cofe in my moods okay
so that's complete and utter nonsense
and that's what I'm saying eventually if
the AI is learning off of
itself that's what I think of our
cartoons will turn into our images will
turn into it will degrade until we're
getting that it makes me think that AI
would realize that and be like we need
human Ingenuity we need to preserve
these human creatives somehow so that it
would incentivize our system to maintain
those no that that is making the
assumption that there is a sentient
being running the these things it is not
the the the AI doesn't care about the
things you care about you as a human
want to preserve human Ingenuity the AI
all it wants is input output there's no
emotional desire or tradition or
anything it's just quite literally like
you give me picture I make picture you
think it'll decide like whatever gets
more clicks is what's what we need to
make more of or will it have morality
will it understand morality it's quite
literally just going to be like what is
I make yeah that's it input output it's
going to search internet look at picture
then it's going to output something
based on that picture eventually you're
going to get copies of copies of copies
and I I
suppose it's you know when we look at
the turn of the century of the 1900s you
had this argument that horse poop was
going to flood the streets you guys know
about this and they were like there were
articles being written saying like soon
cities will be manure farms and you'll
be unable to live and work because horse
manure will be everywhere and then we we
invented the car now there's no horse
poop anywhere but now we're complaining
about climate change it's possible the
people who are building AI get to a
point where they say we need to give AI
the ability to detect images made by Ai
and sounds made by Ai and block it from
entering its learning it's like
preventing inbreeding you don't want the
AI to inbreed it's a good analogy that's
exactly what it is I think we're going
through that with plastic right right
now too people are like we're going to
have trash everywhere and then we'd
invent some technology that reuses it
all turns all plastic into graphine I
wonder if you're going to have the
ability for AI to identify things
created by AI right now there's this
technology called amp modeling uh and
what they do is they actually take an
amplifier and they take a c a speaker
cabinet and they just have it uh they
just run a a a computer program that
runs the amp through
um through all the the whatever the
frequencies that you could that that it
does and essentially what it's doing is
it's copying the amp yeah so you model
the amp then you can put it into a
computer or a plug-in and then as you
change stuff on the amp that's in the
computer it sounds like if you're
changing stuff that's on the real amp
okay I don't know how it works exactly
but my point being
if if because the
if if a computer can model an amp it can
actually get the data right get it close
enough so that way it sounds the same it
makes the because you're what you're
doing is you're making the frequency
you're making the the actual speaker
respond the same way that the amp would
make a real speaker response so your
computer is imitating it and there's a
real Motion in in the real world to move
the the you know the the stuff to or
move the air so you can hear it so if it
can mimic that closely I mean Can it can
it can it make something that AI
couldn't detect because at the end of
the day it is just binary right it's
zeros and ones right so how would an AI
detect what arranged the zeros and on
dude it's like it's like what
synthesizers and dance music that I make
like if you know how this syn is
supposed to sound on the in the actual
vintage version and you can already make
those parameters effect the same way
that it would you can fool even somebody
who knows those or sense as long as you
understand oh it's going to variate over
this amount of time I'm going to put
this parameter on here and variate that
that particular parameter over this
amount of time and it's in almost IND
discernable the the computer that's that
available now is so much more powerful
than something made in 83 or 7 whatever
you know it's and and and and and again
to the computer at the very basic level
it's just zeros and ones how do you tell
what arranged the zeros and ones how do
you tell that it was a human that took a
picture that's how those zeros and ones
got arranged on the you know whatever
format you're putting it on or they were
arranged by an AI because at the end of
the day that file is just zeros and ones
so part of the controversy around Sports
Illustrated is that not just the AI but
we also have two stories which are
component of this and that was the
transgender models that were placed on
the swimsuit ads the debate here is uh
you want to pull pull these up so we
have you have Kim petris this is a
biological male and then you have this
individual Elena bloom also a biological
maale and these are the uh this was
swimsuit 2021 and swimsuit 2023 someone
tweeted uh some journalist said they did
not get woke and go broke they were
going broke and tried to get woke as a
means to save themselves which I find
very funny the argument then becomes
your company is going under you know
that dudes like looking at pictures of
like scantily clad women so you decide
to put males on your cover that's like a
like look the the the the Sports
Illustrated swimsuit model Edition was
always to get dudes all excited hot and
bothered till they' buy the magazine
whatever or read the magazine putting
dudes on it like biological males that
look like women that have like gotten
surgery and hormones that probably
pissed off a lot of guys like look if
look if you're trans you do your trans
thing you be you go go live your life
but I got to tell you it is trans people
have made the argument it is dangerous
for them if they go out to to a bar and
a guy is like hitting on them and then
finds out they're actually trans it's
dangerous that people can get violent
what do you what do you think Sports
Illustrated when all of these dudes are
like yeah I'm going to pick up this
there's like some chick on the cover and
they're like wait a minute what the
they're going to get mad about it in the
same way like that is a commonly held
belief among trans people why would
Sports illustrate like perhaps the
company's going under but all they did
was was accelerate their decline yeah I
don't I don't understand that whole
thing about trying to appeal to like
that audience or whatever when it's a
fraction of you know the general
population and obviously you know not
their base same thing with like budl or
like Harley-Davidson or all of these
other people um like it's just a
fraction of the overall audience not
only Their audience so but but I I think
if you break it down it all comes down
to AI will replace all media yeah
seriously why why would any dude buy a
buy a magazine or go to Sports
Illustrated to look at a woman in a
bikini right this is the issue so
they're like we'll try anything and
they're hoping that woke activists will
pretend to like it in reality all the
dudes who used to buy Sports Illustrated
or the Victor or or pick up a Victoria
Secret catalog for for for doing Dirty
Deeds let go on the internet now dude
I'm looking at sport who owns Sports
Illustrated it's company called
authentic Brands group who so generic
who owns authentic Brands group well
there's two two companies this is some
investment capital firms own them CVC
Capital partners and HPS Investment
Partners own authentic Brands group this
company has been turned into a skin suit
by people with global agendas this they
they care nothing about the survival of
Sports Illustrated they bought it and
they've they've turned it into something
that it wasn't I don't know who who they
are exactly but the headquarters is in
Luxembourg uh of CVC capital and the
headquarters of HPS could be anybody is
in New York city so that's a it's both a
luxemborg
Bourgeois how do you say that Bish
luxemburgish company and an American
company co-own the company that owns
Sports
Illustrated yeah and that could
literally be anybody could be anybody
dude yeah what company the company that
owns Sports illustr the company that
owns Sports Illustrated is called
authentic Brands group and then the
company that owns that there's two
investment Capital firms that own
authentic Brands group I mean at the end
of the day I think everything is is
owned by or every every large company is
is owned by an events Capital you know
um they I mean yeah like even like
conquered music group The the last label
that I was on they owned by an
investment Capital company group or
whatever I think we're we're we're
already people don't understand this too
we're AI music is already here oh oh
yeah as as a as an aside Sports
illustrator got bought by this authentic
Brands group in 2019 so I wouldn't be
shocked if that's when they're downfall
became you know would be cool if like it
was 10 years ago somebody at Google he's
like like working on his computer and
then he's like all right that's the
final line of code if I press enter I'll
I'll have created a very rudimentary
artificial intelligence he presses enter
and then that is the singularity point
where the AI turns on and then just
starts reading the internet compiling
data getting smarter and smarter
exponentially now we're at the point
where we are totally oblivious to the
fact that there is a sentient omniscient
AI machine buying up everything and
everything that's happening with the
collapse of these institutions and
wokeness is an AI entity like
manipulating stock markets feeling value
gaining control and eventually we're
just going to be like who owns anything
it's this weird company called you know
sensient omnicient ink what is this and
then you know it turns out one AI just
bought and owns everything it does annoy
me when you see who owns that company
and then it's another company and you're
like well who owns that other company
and it's the company that they own
you're like what okay by Design I think
I reach the top when I see that black
rock owns Vanguard and Vanguard owns
Black Rock portions of it they own
portions of each other so crazy well I
mean like they do own portions of each
other sure and that's that's fair but
like the thing is the people that own
Black Rock and it's like there are big
you know big uh big time owners oron
people that own I don't know if they're
trilon apparently there are
trillionaires the people the people that
own like the majority Shares are big but
the rest of that is like everybody else
in America because like all the 401ks
and everyone's retirements and
everyone's you know Investments and
stuff all that stuff is mixed up in in
Black Rock and and uh you know what
Vanguard and stuff like that State
Street those are State yeah so it's like
yes it is true that there's big money in
those corporations and and in those uh
investment firms and stuff but it's also
like Grandma and and moms you know her
the the the fixed income that she's on
it's like that stuff's all invested
there too so it's I just it's people get
so wrapped up in the in the bagging on
obviously bad things that they do do
they forget that there are good they
they start bagging on capitalism as a
concept when they do that and I think
that corporate corporatism is a whole
other Beast I don't think these
corporations should have should have the
rights of people I don't know when what
the the E I mean I guess I see it from
the businessman's perspective and the
businessmen are the ones that are
writing the laws so I see why they did
that for themselves I don't like that
though well what are you thinking isn't
it to like prosecute to help them hold
them accountable I don't remember exact
I don't why they got personhood I don't
know the actual just legally I think
it's just legally the thought process
behind it is they're the corporations
are made of people they're culpable and
they're made of people you know it's
like they're they're the people the
corporation isn't an entity that is
removed from the people that uh that
yeah you know make it this is it says
corporate personhood or Jurish jial P
personality is the legal notion that a a
jial person such as a corporation
separately from its Associated human
beings like owners managers or employees
has at least some of the legal rights
and responsibilities enjoyed by natural
persons in most companies a corporation
has the same rights as a natural person
to hold property enter into contracts
and to Sue or be sued yeah corporations
owning property that's a bit of a uh an
issue we're looking at because black
Rock's been buying up a bunch of land
they're going try and make people
Perpetual renters but Tim ow owns this
house and this is and like or Tim's
corporation owns this house and it's and
and stuff so it's like that's actually
not true small corporations maybe okay I
don't know I don't know how your
business is struck isck I don't I I
speaking I'm speaking out of turn but it
is it is very normal for like a
corporation like you know like hurts
rental cars owns cars like why like the
people that owns let me let me tell you
the nightmare scenario that we are
entering okay I'm hanging out the local
casino several months ago or or last
year and I have an issue so I say I'd
like to speak with you know the manager
you know I I I put on my Caren wig and I
said I want to talk to the manager and
they said there isn't one that was it
I'm not kidding modern large
corporations like casinos don't have
managers they do to a certain degree but
what ends up happening is they say okay
I have a security issue and a security
guy shows up and says I'm here and I'm
in charge of security I say who's the
boss who's the guy who like is in charge
of the casino that I could talk to about
my problem they go there isn't one there
are small managers for each individual
area I ended up getting help because one
of the guys who handles the food for the
casino is a fan of the show and I ended
up meeting him and he says I'll reach
out to someone and then someone else
there was no boss you know I noticed
that but but but so we've it's not just
this one Casino thing that's happened
there have been many instances where
I've gone to you know it's like a
smaller business you don't really it's a
small business the owner is right there
the guy making you the sandwich is the
guy who owns the shop and says okay I'll
make you a new sandwich I'm the boss I
eat the cost you go to a sandwich shop
corporate sandwich shop and you say I
want you made my sandwich wrong like sir
I just make $10 an hour I have no idea
what to do and you can't get anything
done this is I noticed this when social
media appeared because it was for the
first time in my life when I started
using Google uh I was like I can't
contact anyone at Google I don't know
how to get through to someone all in the
90s and in the 80s if you ever used a
product every day you could always call
a number to talk to someone that would
elevate your call to the next person
there's always a way to get through to
that company as far as I could tell and
then social media appear and they were
just overloaded it's they're too
centralized power with so few people now
they don't and then to accept that
allows for what you're saying now other
companies are doing it easy example you
start a business uh I knew a guy who who
uh had a business online where he sold
products one day his sales evaporated
and it was because Google changed their
search algorithm so it used to be that
if you looking for product you'd type in
the search bar product search bar
product the website would be in the top
five and he worked really hard to make
sure he had the proper SEO and he was
making six figures Google changes their
algorithm he's gone and there's nothing
that was done and nothing can be done
that's like opening a brick and mortar
shop and one day you wake up and your
Shop's been moved to the middle of a
field 100 miles away it's just that's no
sales anymore the problem here not only
that but also who are you going to
call there is no customer service for
any of these companies now with with
Twitter and it's changing because you
subscribe to blue or premium or or
business all of a sudden people are
tweeting at you so we we bought ads I
bought a commercial for Alex Stein's
Prime Time grind two times caffeine
casper.com and it was not it was like
rejected so I tweeted Twitter still has
not approved this ad we're putting
$25,000 behind this Alex Stein
commercial and immediately someone from
X responded saying on it and hit the
button got it going it it has been since
the dawn of the internet age that
Twitter is basically the place you go to
get things done got a problem on YouTube
tweet at them that will get things done
yep I've noticed that and then I
responded to uh uh the ex staff that I
apologized for dead naming X by calling
it Twitter and would not do it again
yeah I saw that I I started following
the the person that you were talking
with they pretty quickly the point is we
all know the situation we're in where
when you have a problem with a company
you are running on these platforms ain't
nobody to call Simply cease to exist
centralized
that's a big problem with centralized
Authority is the lack of response that
you get from it like that's one one of
the wonderful things about lots of
little companies is that they're all
kind of beholden to each other and that
there's Market competition and if they
don't follow through with your complaint
then you'll move on to the next store
they'll go out of business but with
centralized Authority they're like we
can eat a 90% loss so screw off it's
cheaper not to hire the people I think
we should have a regulation that you
have to have human customer
service at a certain scale of of profit
and Company so uh if you're a small
company you should have customer service
of course if you're a big company you
should have to have it and by big I mean
if if the profit threshold reaches a
certain point and this the size of the
of the user base so the challenge here
is if you mandate a company as customer
service they could just literally be
like yeah our profit margins are 2%
we'll go to business it's just not
possible and then it's like well raise
the cost nobody will buy the product for
that cost it's like okay well that I get
but if your profit margin is a certain
threshold and the amount of users you
have is a certain threshold it should be
in my opinion regulated that Facebook
and you know Instagram whatever those
platforms Tik Tok all have human
customer service you can call on the
phone and instantly talk to somebody or
a moderate weit time I think is fair if
you're waiting 10 minutes not a big deal
but right now there's nothing so they
expect and this is this would be great
for the economy because right now the
problem is these these platforms like
Facebook meta they expect us to start a
business on their platform utilizing
social their the social media platform
to attract customers and they could
erase Us in two seconds without any any
any protection there's got to be
protection because our economy could
collapse overnight we're at the point
now where social where the internet is
it if Google vanished overnight our
economy would tank not everything would
go belly up but enough would that it
would cause a Cascade failure we need
protections now I'm sure every
libertarian in the world is screaming no
no no but I'm looking at it like some
form of antitrust and every libertarian
is still screaming no no no but I'm not
a staunch libertarian so you know take
that Big L Libertarians yeah especially
like if you're basing your company uh on
social media like Facebook or whatever
they always argue too they're like oh we
we could not like you know provide a
personal response to everyone or
whatever but like x with like even all
of their staff cuts and stuff like as a
perk of like being like um you know
organization or whatever or even like
having premium you can now like chat
with you know human beings from like the
premium account like if you have
problems I remember like when it was
Twitter with Twitter support they used
to do that you could DM like at support
or whatever it was um then they stopped
doing that and then they eventually
stopped replying to even emails and
you'd get like you know a generated
response or whatever which happened in
my case like when I got banned or
whatever I was left for like two years
without you know human contact uh from
someone at Twitter so um to Tim's point
it's like if you're going to base your
entire business on you know a platform
you should be able to get customer
service I guess if it's a free platform
to like YouTube costs nothing to use I
understand why but you're saying like
with premium you're paying money into
the system now they have a a Duty or
they maybe they should have a duty to
have give you some sort of customer yeah
or if you're in a relationship with them
like monetization like a a YouTube
Partner or you know just on Facebook or
whatever with monetization like you're
spending your resources and some people
have entire teams and dedicate those
resources to make content specifically
for that platform of course they give
you money but then you know you spend 10
years doing it and then they cut you off
with no explanation like totally
shouldn't be able to what about like if
you had to pay to get a customer service
rep you had to pay like n 90 cents or
something I the subscription thing is
you know a better deal because that kind
of gives you kind of like an insurance I
would say you know to have that
beneficial support you're supporting the
company by paying for the subscription
and then they're supporting you back by
giving you customer service and perks
the other option would be if the
community could be your customer support
but you really sometimes you need to get
through a corporate authorization well
like like in in Tim's case like he
publicly posted about it and that's it
wasn't like he filed a support ticket or
whatever like an ex-employee replied
publicly like and you know other people
probably helped bring uh that to their
like attention um publicly so that was
one instance where that happened so AI
customer service is that where you think
these companies are headed that's the
goal I think well a lot of them like
start off like that like for example
like they have I'm looking at it right
now it says like missing check mark
Revenue sharing refund requests like it
starts you off so it does like the
little like Small Talk work so that's
not a waste of the uh time of the person
so it's kind of like an AI assistant I
would say um you know it expedites it so
it saves the time on the human being it
does help I when I was working with
minds and we were taking customers like
they would sent me I'm having a problem
logging in I'm I'm getting an error when
I go to all I need I need your browser I
need what version of your browser it is
I need your your operating system
version and I need to know a screenshot
of what you're looking at while you're
and if those things aren't applied
immediately when I receive the complaint
I have to ask them to send it to me good
luck and then I got to wait for their
response and I've got 90 other things
queued up it's like dude I need an AI
parsing all that beforehand so I have
the required data I need their name I
need where they're at what all their
info so that I can answer the question
in one shot and then move on I'm going
to I'm going to change the subject I'm
going tell you guys a story last night I
had a very strange dream I had a dream
that I was watching John
Oliver and he would just not shut up
about how much he loved Alec Baldwin
gosh I swear this was my dream last
night and then you know I wake up when
my alarm goes off and then I was like
that was a really weird dream I started
thinking about it I'm like yeah but like
it's probably my brain basically cycling
the data of how like liberal person
personalities just will constantly
defend each other and I was thinking
like Alec Baldwin's going to be redeemed
and they're going to like bring him back
into the fold and get him to do more
Democrat activism in 2024 and then uh
today it was announced Alec Baldwin is
charged with involuntary manslaughter by
New Mexico grand jury I must have been
having some kind of premonition that's
the only explanation I was having a
psychic vision for when Alec Baldwin is
found not guilty or or actually either
and then the liberal media runs full
speed to defend him even though he
killed this woman and and I want I want
to stress it is a statement of fact Alec
Baldwin killed that
woman anyway he also shot a guy he
killed her and then hit the guy behind
her yeah so this is the big news though
he's being recharged again and I got to
be honest I'm actually going to defend
Alec baldon a little bit on this one it
is kind of crazy that they're like going
after him again yeah who's who's
charging him uh I think it's it's New
Mexico yeah grand jury well grand jury
indicted but it's the special prosecutor
k morsey and Jason Lewis how come he's
not protected under under uh double
jeopardy I I don't think he was tried I
think if if if you're found not guilty
but to be fair actually like maybe this
is what he deserves there there there
have been a lot of people especially
people on the right saying we should not
let prosecutors just keep doing this
like if they if they run you through the
charges and the charges fall off you're
done but I'm kind of like yeah yeah hold
on Justice mlet should get charged like
a prosecutor letting the bad guy go does
not mean we should be like oh well I
guess he got away with it right so yeah
I don't know man I I air on the side of
less it just depends on the situ I I
agree that a prosecutor letting bad guys
go on purpose over and over again is a
problem but well I fear that Alec
Baldwin has killed and if he is let out
he will kill
again yeah his interactions with people
in the public are uh like when he just
like did he slam someone against the
door or whatever and punch someone like
punch shove but I'm only I'm only most I
I be clear I am mostly kiding mostly I
don't really think there's a strong
probability Al K but I do believe that
there is a probability that he does not
that it's a great one but it's higher
than the average person because we know
he's got a short temper and I think when
you look at the data of this of this
when you the data when you look at the
evidence in this case I I think it's
greater than chance that he
intentionally killed this woman I think
it's greater than chance he had come on
guys we've been over this so many times
but I know a lot of people don't know
the story let me let me let me give you
a version of events assuming I'm the
prosecutor okay I'm not going to get
give you an actual prosecutorial
breakdown because I'm not a prosecutor
but I'm going to say this I'm not going
to give you the media's version I'm not
going to be nice to this man let me tell
you a story Alec Baldwin the producer
and finer of a film was having disputes
with his staff who were upset over pay
and safety he had numerous meetings with
them he had a dinner scheduled with the
woman in question the victim who died
some point while on set Alec baldon was
having an argument with her because she
kept telling him what to do but was not
the director she's a cinematographer
Alec Baldwin expressed in an interview
his frustration over this in one of
these scenes he was drawing a weapon
pointing it at her and pulling the
trigger he did just that firing a live
round through her chest killing her and
striking The Man Behind her it was later
found that Baldwin had live ammunition
in his gun belt he is not supposed to
have live ammunition on his person but
he did live ammunition was not only on
his person but was in the weapon that he
pointed at the woman pulled the trigger
killing her he later lied and said he
did not pull the trigger now does that
sound like an accident to you no where
did where did where did the ammunition
come from did he put it there or did
they come from the prop now on Cross
examination I'm sorry good good defense
will ask a witness where did the ask
Alec where where did the ammunition come
from which says I don't know and my
response as a prosecutor would be
like I don't think it is a reasonable
defense the live bullets I had in my gun
belt that was loaded into my gun that I
pointed at a woman pulled the trigger
and killed her and then went but I have
no idea where those bullets came from
who loaded the gun did he load it cuz if
he loaded it you the Armor but which is
um what was her name um now of course it
is important to break this down because
this is how criminal Criminal Courts
work I think the armor handed it to the
assistant director who handed it to Alec
Baldwin and said hot this is the
importance cold gun he said cold gun
this is the import of Defense if a
prosecutor says Alec Baldwin had live
ammunition on his person fact in his gun
belt fact was he supposed to have no
there should be no live ammunition here
the gun was loaded with live ammunition
he pointed the gun pulled the trigger
and killed her ladies and gentlemen this
man did it intentionally it's murder and
they're charging with involuntary
manslaughter now of course the defense
would then say where did the bols come
from did you load the gun why were you
pointing the gun to break down those
points as to why it really happened that
being said is a fact he was feuding with
this woman he was in disputes over over
uh issues on set involving my
understanding was pay and
security this woman who was frustrating
him he then shoots and kills did I heard
that they were shooting with the gun
like they were shooting target prti
they're going on the back and shooting
can according to other people that work
on the IDE the idea that you would use a
live gun in a in a movie like that I
mean there's all kinds of prop houses
and and you know using a gun that you
were just actually shooting target
practice that's oh is it confirm that
they were using the same gun Alec had on
him that's what I'm asking I'm not I
don't know for sure I heard that
according to crew and cast that they
would go out after work and shoot at
can's out back so there was live Amun
ammunition on set which there was not
supposed to be any live ammunition on
set my guess here is that Alec
intentionally fantasized about killing
Helena Hutchin he pointed his gun at her
which he thought was empty was was blank
and was pretending to shoot her by
pulling the trigger just out of like
fantasy because he was so angry at her
and then someone on the set's like yo
I'm going to frame this piece of garbage
I'm going to put bullets in his gun and
see what
happens I mean not my opinion is that he
did it on purpose The Perfect Crime I
mean I'm not kidding The Perfect Crime
oh no I was just doing a movie and the
gun that I had that was loaded with
bullets that I had on my gun
belt like I I mean I I got to be honest
man if this wasn't a movie set this guy
whoever like if Alec ball was on the
street and he was like someone else
handed me the gun they'd be like what
someone else handed me the gun told me
to point it at him the the the the woman
that got shot she told me to do it
they'd be like he paid me 100 Grand to
do it like why did you do it cuz he was
paying me like that's the same reason
that you shot did it in the movie sir
you shot woman yeah but she told me to
over and over again how did the bullets
get in the gun I don't know someone else
hand it to me sir you have the bullets
on you no idea it's all just hand it to
me and I let it all happen he was the
producer one of The Producers he was
really his responsibility to check
everything I mean him him blindly
trusting the armor and the ad is like
tell you I don't believe that I just
don't believe it for a second I don't
know what happened and what didn't
happen but I know that uh you know I'm
convinced that there there's enough
evidence to have a have a a trial but I
think it should be a murder
trial uh they're getting him an
involuntary manslaughter and the premise
there is basically like he was
irresponsible with a gun and because
he's the producer of the film he has
more responsibility over who's AR
loading and everything you know they
only charge what they think they can
prove so I mean even even if someone
agrees with you they have to be able to
prove it yeah without without a shadow
of a doubt I don't think murder is on
the table because there's just unknowns
I think murder's on the table easily I
don't know he was handed the gun it
wasn't like he loaded it if he loaded it
that's one
thing I suppose the argument then
is imagine a scenario where a guy shoots
and kills a woman and it's like we can't
charge him with murder because someone
else gave him the gun it's like no you
charged them as an
accomplice yeah but did he know there
were bullets in it he pointed a gun at a
person and shot them yeah but now we now
we get to the circumstance it's a
movie Why okay Fair Point fair point
there was a circumstance in which he
should be showing off the weapon why did
he have bullets on him they were
supposed to be blank
and they' been people were scattering
them in
with then I think it's fair to say they
need to investigate as to where the
bullets came from who bought them who
brought them in and they need to trace
from point A to point B but my my issue
with this is that you've got motive
you've you've got motive opportunity and
possession of the ammo and the weapon I
don't understand how it's like okay fine
Fair Point that they're like I don't
know if we can prove it because on a
movie set that just means the Perfect
Crime oh yeah you want to get away with
it do it on a movie set because then
everyone's going to be like even if
you've got the bullets you've got the
gun you're angry at the person you're
screaming at him and then you shoot him
well it was on a movie set that's the
reason he was the producer too cuz he
set it all up like to your point it's
his job to do it it's his job to do it
that way in which he could get away with
it I don't go that far some people argue
that this woman helina Hutchins was
working on a child predator documentary
and then she gets hired for this film
and nah that's that's that's way too
circuitous but the issue actually is
quite simple Alec bald wanted to make a
movie he's a very hot-headed guy he's
hit people before he screams at his
daughter we know he's got a temper he
had a motive he was fighting with the
staff there were problems on set they
were threatening like walk off I think I
could be wrong it's been a long time
since we covered this and he ends up
having a meeting with her at dinner
apparently in an interview He was
discussing how she kept frustrating him
by telling him what to do despite the
fact she's not the director so he's
angry with her she's causing him
problems he's a hotthead this is a
pattern of behavior he's had in the past
violent outbursts he has the mean to
kill her the means to kill her he has
the opportunity to do so he was found
with the bullets and he and he lied
about pulling the
trigger so I mean
like I I I kind of feel like you line up
all those circumstances and at the the
lightest you can get with it is a
conspiracy to Comm commit murder but he
was handed the gun someone else brought
the bullets handed him the bullets put
the bullets in his gun belt okay he was
framed somebody wanted her dead and
framed him there's a murder somebody
wanted Alec to kill somebody so that he
would go to jail that's what I'm getting
out of this Alec Baldwin's been doing
action movies for decades and and this
is the thing about murder we talked
about this when the story first broke
here's a guy who's been on set for
decades handling weapons and in this one
instance I like you know I I don't look
I'll put it this way a guy is in the
street and he gets into a fight and he
defends himself and it and ends up
killing one of the guys we say it's
self-defense he didn't know going happen
let's say it's mutual
combat there actually is in law if you
are a trained fighter you can get
aggravated uh uh modifications to your
charges because you know what you're
doing can cause this harm so in the
instance that Alec Baldwin's a who
has no idea what's going on and fires a
gun and goes Whoopsie Daisy
sure but then you have to you also have
to mention to the jury and to the people
you you expect me or a reasonable person
to believe that a man who's been working
in films an action mov movies with guns
for decades did not know about these
issues okay then we're dealing with
negligent homicide it's murder because
of gross negligence on the part of Alec
Baldwin not involuntary manslaughter
which I don't know what the laws are in
New Mexico if they actually have those
those uh uh if they actually have that
in their in in their codified in their
statutes yeah I kind of I'm looking
where Phil's at right now I think you
make a lot of sense they charge with
what they think they can get and it's
pretty obvious that he was resultant in
her death meaning it was an involuntary
manslaughter at
minimum I wonder what they're going to
do with the armor did they charge the
armorer and the assistant director for
handing in the weapon they charge the
armor so I mean it's it's it's wild to
me that the precedent being set here is
actually like you can get away with
murder on a movie set but but but I'll
be completely fair I I don't think most
people re realize this the majority of
premeditated murder is never solved yeah
never man like I got to tell you anybody
body who's ever actually had to deal
with police and like serious crimes
understands Ain no solving any of this
your car gets stolen sorry have a nice
day your car's gone Chop Shop gone
products gone seal numbers all gone
there's no there's no searching for it
the cops are going to be like well write
it down and have a good day your car is
that's it it's over the likelihood they
find your car not going to happen are
these airpods useful for that kind of
thing people are air poding their stuff
air TX air TXS tracking their materials
I mean but they are useful that means
you you can find it but criminals use
air tags to track you but do do you I
mean are you going to go there to
wherever the car is you don't know where
the car want it's like the other thing
too is it what tells you that airpods
are moving or air tags are moving with
you if it's not yours so one thing that
criminals do is they'll they'll put a
tag on your car they'll they'll when
they'll be out in the city there will be
a car that's really really nice they'll
stick an air tag on it and then they can
see you know let's say you're let's say
you're at a really high-end restaurant
or or a casino mhm and you're you're
driving a super high-end car of some
sort something like you know $80,000
$100,000 car they're going to tag your
car wait for you to go home and they're
going to know where you live I had um
when I went to San Francisco the first
time I parked my car was going to look
at an apartment to rent I left my
backpack in the back seat I was gone in
for 15 minutes I came out my window was
shattered backpack was gone called the
cops and I was like hey they stole my
it's a it's a laptop so there's probably
some tracking and I had this like hope
for a week that maybe it would turn up
yo that shit's gone oh yeah theft is
like there's no finding it no not at all
I got bricked and immediately it's a
theft I I had a uh this is not even a
theft I had a uh phone lost while I was
out with my friends someone took it and
kept it I used find my phone and went to
the house where it was and I called the
police I first I knocked in the door
nobody answered and so I'm sitting there
waiting be like dude I can't leave my
phone and I know it's here cuz I'm
looking at like my I I have two iPhone
and Android and uh one I use as a camera
and one I used as uh uh like my actual
personal device so I called the police
and I was like yeah hi I you know need
some help I lost my phone somehow I
don't know if it was stolen or if it was
dropped or what happened but it looks
like someone recovered it brought it to
their house I used find my phone I'm
here and they were like sir do not try
to get your phone back and I was like no
no I'm in Williamsburg it's I'm I'm I'm
not in a dangerous place I'm in like a
upscale hipster place and they were like
sir you need to leave right now and then
I was like okay my phone is quite
literally 5T from me can you please come
and help me get it back and they said no
and if I tried I would be
arrested really yeah trespassing and
like they're like do not what cop wants
to be like in New York I'm going to go
and and get into a hot conflict over a
phone yeah that they're
they're going to be like nah dude your
phone's gone on I'm not going to
potentially get into a shootout with
some some you know gang banger over your
your phone go buy a new one get
insurance next time and I'm just like
it's right there I'm like the other side
of this door is my phone guess and I
can't get it back and no one will answer
and they would not and so I waited like
eight hours or whatever nobody came out
phone was just there and then I just was
like screw it I left it's nuts yeah that
was a long time ago brutal I wonder what
happened to that phone probably got sold
smashed or something I mean they
couldn't open it return now I have uh
they have these security apps you can
get so I have this on my phones where if
someone tries to open it and fails it
takes a picture of your face oh and then
it uploads it to the internet that's
pretty cool emails it to you uh well
that is one option it can do a bunch of
things can post it right to your Twitter
that would be awesome this dude stole my
phone but the problem with that is if
you like if like let's say you you're
you're like out of the shower and you're
like fingers are pruny you touch it it
takes a picture of your face and tweets
it out and you're like you know just out
of the shower or something yeah bad but
anyway yeah so Alec Baldwin killed that
lady that's pretty Undisputed well
Undisputed it it's clearly Undisputed
but like I said I mean he's got there's
definitely enough you know to to put put
him on trial for at least manslaughter
but it they if they can't prove that if
they don't believe they can prove that
you did you know the crime beyond a
shadow of a doubt there's so much
politics involved in in what a DA
decides to prosecute and what they don't
you know because it is bad for their
career if they accuse people of stuff
and then they don't convict so you get a
like a good DA has like a 99% conviction
rate so they don't go after people
unless they can unless they're sure they
can you know nail them you guys someone
made someone made a good point they uh
they posted about this uh rukov said uh
that a YouTuber shot her boyfriend and
killed him she was not trying to kill
him they were trying to do a stunt where
he would hold up like a couple books and
then she would shoot the books and he
would catch the bullet in the books or
something like this except the bullet
went through the books and he died she's
in prison I guess yeah
yeah what are no she she must be out of
prison by now she went to prison though
I don't that I'm not 100% sure that she
should go to prison for that cuz he was
an active participant that's the
argument with Alec Baldwin oh
interesting she wasn't an active
participant getting shot
he wasn't she wasn't supposed to helina
Hutchins was telling him to point the
gun that's the argument he's towards me
she's filming she's like I want you to
do these things oh pointed at me and
shoot was it wasn't in the script to
pull the trigger right I don't believe
it I don't believe it for a second I
think Al Baldwin killed dead what was
the double jeopardy you said with the
Baldwin case that he couldn't be tried
again was he charged before charges
before I think they were bringing
charges then dropped them what were the
charges they dropped I think it was let
me let me let me look it up
yeah I don't know I think it was the
same thing the rust shooting
incident so uh let's see background uh
Union disputes and safety concerns look
at this like the boss is fighting with
the staff has a meeting with a woman
he's complaining about takes then then
shoots and kills her yeah but it was a
movie so that's fine H dude I don't I
don't buy it man I mean they were
actually complaining about safety like
dude the the piece lined up so perfectly
for this to argue it's a it's it was a
CO is just nonsense to me she's
complaining to him about the safety of
all these guns well that proves it it
was an accident see she was complaining
about safety and then she died I will
not consider that an accident someone
intentionally seeded bullets into his
gun so that he would shoot and kill
somebody he had the bullets on him they
they searched him and they were like
Alec has the
bullets yeah I mean is were they the
actual were they the same bullets that
go in the gun yeah yes Alec Baldwin had
the bullet let me let me pull this up I
I don't know
man like I said I mean there's not
really like I don't feel like there's a
problem establishing motive or
establishing opportunity or ability the
record um it was an involuntary
manslaughter charge dropped in April of
2023 and then Helena Hutchin also was
charged with uh involuntary manslaughter
they cited reasons for uh for dropping
it was that they needed more time to
investigate they
yeah which is an interesting reason to
drop the charges so I didn't know you
could charge somebody and then drop the
charges and then recharge them the same
thing maybe it's because he wasn't found
not guilty was brought to trial yeah you
have to go through trial you have to be
actually tried not uh just dude I I feel
like if they open the can of worms on
this and all the cast and crew a lot of
them are going to get would get popped
for like firing live rounds on set at
the very least which you're not supposed
to do a lot of people get blacklisted
from the industry and and I don't know
that necessarily they were committing
Crimes by doing that but they were
definitely violating um policy company
policy there was not supposed to be any
live ammunition on
set well like with that too I don't like
I don't think they'll go after them
because there's not like you know unless
they recorded themselves doing it like
evidence of them doing it but obviously
with the murder or you know just death
of her there's the evidence that it
happened so
and then the shooting of the director
who took one in the shoulder yeah that
was that was the same bullet that wasn't
it yeah it went
through hit him I don't think there's
any charges for that I don't think
there's any charges for that for him
hitting that guy gonna say I don't why I
mean why wouldn't they reckless
endangerment you know or I mean they
could get him on some kind of battery
charge or something like that because
they actually actually did he he did inj
him and if they're GNA charge him for
killing the woman why wouldn't they
charge him for shooting the other guy
makes sense
yeah is he is he what are all what are
his all of his
charges I don't know it's it's hard to
find this stuff though because they've
Rewritten so many articles about it yeah
is but the big news so what what what
like five live rounds were found and I
think a handful of them were in his gun
belt so I'm trying to find that specific
citation but it's mostly been removed
from
uh uh yeah he's he's he has criminal
culpability in the death of Helen
Hutchins and the shooting of Joel Souza
so yeah he's they're going to they're
they're going to charge him for a
shooting the Dude too oh okay
so this is the first I've heard that he
had the bullets on his belt no we we we
talked about it like 15 times bro it's
just been so long first I've seen yeah
maybe it's been a while we've got the
evidence yeah cuz it was in the original
investigation and when that happened it
was like boom there it is yeah Alec
Baldwin had live rounds on his person I
think that makes it open and
shut yeah I mean like I said
I um I think I might have found it in
the Vanity Fair article but they had he
had the two loose 45 bullets were
discovered on top of a prop cart a third
was in the Bandelier worn by actor Jason
akles and a fourth was in the gun belt
worn by Baldwin a fifth was found in the
box of dummy ammunition with gooder so
he had a live round in his gun belt live
round we'll clarify for the for the show
but he had the the live ammunition the
same kind of bullet used for the gun was
on his person yeah I think that that it
was in other another actor's bandier
kind of indicates that he didn't like if
he did do it on purpose and he was the
one that if he was in intending it then
that would have been like a red herring
that he would I just don't think it was
I just think it's it's so dang crazy but
there is the reality of innocent until
proven guilty that if Alec baldon really
wanted to kill this woman takes a
handful of bullets mixes him into a
mixes him into a box puts puts a couple
in his gun belt loads the gun kills her
and then goes but look there's other
bullets over here too like it must have
been somebody else like crazy Alec
Baldwin pointed the gun pulled the
trigger and then lied and said he didn't
pull the trigger and investigators found
he lied the gun does not operate unless
you it's a what is it a single action
meaning you have to the hammer and
pull the trigger yep there's he lied
about it I think there's a strong
possibility I think it's reasonable to
assume the woman he was fighting with
over issues on set he killed he's a
hotthead it's pattern of behavior he had
the means and the motive to do
it yeah punched the guy over the parking
spot but think about this think about
this let's imagine that Alec baldman
really wanted to kill this lady yeah
punch the guy calling his his daughter a
fat pig or whatever a little whatever he
did he's got a temper but imagine this
imagine he he really wanted imagine a
scenario where a guy says he wants to
commit a
murder so he goes onto a movie set where
he knows that or I mean in this instance
they're on a movie set they're having
problems Alec Baldwin decided he could
get away with murder his hypothetical
situation all he had to do was take a
couple of the extra bullets and mix them
into a box and now all of a sudden
everyone's like it must have been an
accident yo where' the bolets come from
why did he pull the trigger and then lie
about it the only this is all that
matters he pulled the trigger killing
her and then lied and claimed he didn't
did you Al do you also remember what he
said about after he shot her he walked
out and wasn't even like attempting to
help her or anything for like 45 minutes
in interview I didn't even know she was
shot like what you pointed a gun at a
woman pulled the trigger she flies back
screaming everyone runs over like she's
dying and you walk out of the room
totally oblivious how do you not know
that she's shot I can't believe he said
that I think I think Alec baldwi
intentionally killed her and did not
know how to explain his behavior which
was irratic and made no
sense so after after he kills her
feeling Justified and satisfied with
having done the deed he gets up and
walks out doesn't render Aid is not
shocked or surprised at what happened
because he did it now Alec baldon kills
a woman intentionally right is he G to
go oh geez oh no how did I I just
pointed a gun and pulled the trigger and
she died I can't believe that happened
if he wanted her dead he would know that
she was going to die he would not react
react with shock at her dying he would
get up and be like yep and he'd walk out
of the room and he's like oh it was only
45 minutes later I realized that she was
actually shot what do you mean you
pointed a gun at her and pulled the
trigger it went bang she falls backwards
two people got hit and everyone's
screaming I don't buy it for a second
dude I and then he has the bullet on him
like yeah I'm sorry man the the whole
the I I didn't know that she was shot
like you shot two people and you didn't
know let's talk about must have known
well oh I I dude he he he's lying about
everything he I'm sorry like we got half
an hour talking about he wanted to do it
anyway here's another story it's Friday
another story Biden to forgive another
$5 billion in student debt for 74,000
borrowers just a week after announcing
separate plan are you effective affected
Yo Joe Biden is pouring gasoline on this
country and lighting it on fire just
going to he's literally he's just trying
to purchase votes this student loan
stuff drives me nuts I actually got my
loans forgiven I it been 25 years and I
hadn't missed a payment which I think is
why so they targeted me first but now
it's just just total extraction of
wealth I don't know where that five
billion is if they told Fanny May or
whoever these loan companies are you're
not getting your money back that's a
different story but if they're printing
five billion to hand it to these private
loan corporations and they're just
forcing you to pay back your loans early
with that's ridiculous because it's
costing us all money it's costing us all
um in in inflation it's it's devaluing
all of our currency by printing money
you know as we watch Sports Illustrated
crumble and Bud Light maybe on the verge
of collapse Joe Biden is just throwing
money in the air while screaming
yeea part of me thinks like we're going
to have to start rebuilding like we're
building the parallel economy we better
Crank That Thing Up man because we're
going to need institutions of our own to
help Sur to so that we
survive yeah and like for for someone
like Biden too it's like you make the
argument that this isn't sustainable you
can't keep doing this it's like why does
he care he's not going to be around and
you know to the point about like
purchasing votes like I mean didn't he
he already tried something like this
also and then it like got struck down or
whatever like these these people are
going to like turn on him too because
you know he's going to overpromise again
and you know I just don't think it's
going to work but even even like the
this plan right there if if it does like
it's it's not going to be sustainable
but he doesn't he doesn't really we had
uh you need people that are are willing
to say I don't want the free money yeah
that's just not going to happen because
the Titanic has hit the iceberg and
everybody's trying to steal as much as
they can before the ship sinks did you
hear the theory that the Titanic got hit
by a UB boat got got sunk okay anyway so
uh I want to talk about that the the the
issue that we're dealing with is that
all of the people a large portion of the
people in this country are just like let
me extract from the system whatever I
can as it's sinking and Joe Biden is
just making it rain and he's like spend
it while you can baby how do we
instantiate honor in the in the species
to be like stop giving me this this
money I don't want it well I mean you
you can't do that to like kids that
already are like you know have already
got the debt you're you're not going to
get kids that have have signed on to
what they assumed was the you know the
deal if I go to school and I study and I
get a good you know get a good uh good
grades I'll get out and I'll get a good
job there will be a job for me that's
not the way that things are are panning
out um and there's not a lot of great
answers for those kids um if they spent
a lot of money on a degree that doesn't
you know doesn't have a job to go with
it or there's no you know no market for
that job they're kind of afed we we had
someone call into the members only show
and said that uh their significant other
was a trooper in
Texas and that they've begun discussing
fears of civil War because the Biden
Administration may start arresting Texas
law
enforcement uh I don't I don't I we have
not confirmed any of this and so Ju Just
the general
idea is is difficult to bring up because
someone's saying it we reached out and
they're like no we don't want to talk
about this we're done and maybe it's
nothing maybe it's F fake news maybe
someone was lying to us to uh try and
sensationalize what's going on but it
the reason why it would make sense in
either direction is that Texas has begun
arresting illegal immigrants and we have
what is quite literally a fort Suter
circumstance where the federal
government is saying this is our
jurisdiction and a state has deployed
armed soldiers to push them out and say
no it's not it's ours now so for with
Fort Suter you have the Union forces at
Fort Suter and the South and the South
Carolina being like hey get out it's
ours now and the union saying no now you
have federal law enforcement On the
Border saying the border is our
Authority and Texas National Guard
deployed armed soldiers to push them out
take control of the the area and begin
arresting uh not illegal
immigrants sooner or later this reaches
ahead in some way either it's going to
be the federal government just gives up
and then other states recognize the
federal Authority is gone and eroded or
the federal government responds with
force or something like that happens I
bring it up in this context because I'm
like everything I see Joe Biden do and
the Democratic
establishment I I don't see any any
long-term planning I see them basically
just setting fire to the curtains before
they leave yeah I don't see the
long-term planning that's it does feel
like all like just kind of let's do
right now what's good for now no they're
like okay we're getting kicked out light
it up I knew a guy once who got evicted
from his apartment so he took Hershey's
syrup and he squirted it into the cracks
of every nook of the building yeah bad
guy and he was like this will teach him
and I'm like I think you already taught
him by not paying rent but this is the
idea like the Democrats they're getting
evicted so they're like Set Fire to the
whole thing well I mean you know the the
fidi Trap stuff comes to mind because
the United States as a strong economic
power with a strong military you know
facing an upand cominging China means
you know conflict and the idea that the
United States needs to be weaker um you
know or a manag decline that's not
something that's that's so farfetched or
something that is hasn't been discussed
like Barack Obama essentially said this
you know said that the United States was
was going to manage being not the only
not the superpower just be another
country among many and that takes a
certain amount of you know of management
to get to the point where the US economy
is not the dominant economy and also
some level of acquiescence CU like half
the country and I don't know the exact
numbers is like screw that no we're
maintaining heiman we are going to be
America First the greatest country on
Earth
try and take it please because you're
not going to get it well I mean yeah
there there are people and the the thing
is yes but a big part of the problem is
this hasn't been proposed to the
American people there's no there was no
like vote about this or or you know or
or you know any kind of inquiry into hey
America do you want to start passing
laws or signing on to treaties that
actually kind of weaken the United
States power you know over or its own
sovereignty you know that that we're we
you know um you know listening to
foreign powers like the you know and Nos
and stuff or or whatever like do do we
want the United States to to sign on to
those things and and a lot of times the
American people don't pay attention and
so because the politicians that do sign
on or that actually are the ones that
are like yes we should plan this kind of
stuff because they that stuff happens
quietly your average person doesn't know
so they get reelected and and also like
if they had been like yo we're going to
reduce the American hegemonic power we
want to get rid of these American
military bases and we're going to
co-parent the Earth with the Chinese
Communist party with the Russians and
with the corporations I'd be open to
that if you give me a plan cuz I don't
like American Military Police
necessarily on its face it's caused a
lot of pain pain and suffering probably
unnecessarily but you better give me
away that that's going to be better than
the LA the stability we've had over the
last 70 years they're already making the
play that I predicted a couple weeks ago
Trump had received support from a mere
56,000 caucus goers amounting to some 7%
of registered Republicans in the state
and just 3% of overall registered voters
in
Iowa they're already pushing the
narrative that Donald Trump is winning
in the absolute minority and they will
use that to justify barring him from
from power so my prediction was they're
going to remove him from the ball in a
bunch of States if they do Trump will
win the electoral college but the you
know if California removes Trump he
loses 10 million rep Republican votes he
was never going to win the electoral
votes in that state anyway but now he's
going to win the general election with
40 million to Biden 70 and they're going
to say this can't be all all the left is
going to say wow no one should be
president for own if with that little
votes this makes no sense that will be
their their in essence C's belly for why
they they're okay with the use of force
to stop Trump from taking the presidency
even after he won the election they'll
say we're not the bad guys Trump didn't
actually win the system is broken he
only got you know
30% and they're going to bet he's not
the real president that's what they did
in Egypt they already want to abolish
the Electoral College so right exactly
and you're going to have Democrats
coming out and being like this country
does not want Donald Trump the majority
of people voted against him we should
not allow him to just use a technic to
take power and turn this country into a
fascist dictatorship they are already
making the argument in Iowa 7% of the
voters voted for Trump and he won that
is not the will of the people they're
making an argument on quote unquote
democracy is that a real number because
I thought that he he pulled what 70% of
the caucus itself but that was only 7%
record low voter turnout for the caucus
it was cold too that day was a bad vote
day and Trump got uh yeah Trump trump
got around 7% of the register of
Republicans wow 7% and so but but this
elections happen what what's the
argument the Democrats the Republicans
who don't show up should have a say no
you don't show up you didn't vote
abstain there you go your vote was
abstain well not showing up isn't a
problem for Democrats they mail you a
ballot yeah I mean and and honestly that
isn't that is worth mentioning if if you
know people are going to say things like
oh well you know showing up you know
blah blah blah blah blah it's like well
you know maybe they should show up if if
their vot's going to count right well
Biden was saying it meant nothing or
whatever Iowa means nothing but like he
finished fourth in Iowa in 2020 and then
uh yeah I know and then also like he got
like you know I think it was like 20
20,000 or something votes and it's you
know and he's the president so I don't
think there's going to be a super
Tuesday and this is this is rough for us
because we're we're trying to plan this
event we want to do a big like live show
in West Virginia but I'm just like man
we're going to spend all this money
setting up this live show and like
making tickets no one's going to be left
yeah well yeah right no Nikki Haley and
desis will drop out we thought we
thought Ron was going to drop out today
cuz he announced a press conference or
something so the Politico announced he
was having a press conference and he
never showed up yeah or he didn't show
up for like a half an hour I don't know
what happened did he ever show up I
don't know I didn't even see I verman
Supreme I tried looking for it and
verman supreme kept popping up S
Champion D Santa sent his champion in
instead well it was funny because Laura
lomer was like why is this man who posed
naked with Mickey Mouse gloves appearing
at around Des Santa event and it's like
it's a good question but I don't blame
Ron for verman Supreme crashing the
party yeah but either either way if he
was invited or not that just like speaks
to the state of his campaign right now
it it speaks to state of state of his
campaign that when Laur lomer went to a
descend his event she got thrown out and
when verman Supreme shows up and jumps
up on stage nobody like he's he's just
allowed he just does his thing I don't
think I think the likelihood is he
wasn't invited he did his thing actually
there's let's pull up the
video we have uh no that's not the video
where's the video at here we go we have
this tweet from Alx on Twitter and uh
awesome that so here's
free ponies free Pon when I say zombie
you say power zombie power zombie he's
up there for a long
time well that's what I'm saying like if
he's like technically a protester and
he's allowed to be up on stage like just
no no way no way where's security this
is this is a disis event this is for
sure confirmed yeah the BS Des sandis is
running for he's get he's going for the
presidential nomination where is
security there's there's no way this was
an accident they let verman Supreme do
this hands down if if the argument is
they didn't know he was going to do it
they let him do it when he jumped up on
stage that's so nuts Laura lomer was
standing in a room and they were like
get her there's a video of a guy in a
wheelchair saying nothing and they walk
up like time to go sir and you mean to
tell me that verman Supreme was able to
jump up on the stage and start saying
when I say zombie you say free or
whatever and everyone's just cheering
for it yeah Rhonda santis let this
happen now I I got no issue with verman
I like that he mocks the system so you
know no beef I I I question why he got
naked with Mickey Mouse gloves I find it
to be very strange I'm just happy that
he's not around the Libertarians anymore
verman is I think he's an anarchist I
don't know that he's like a far leftist
I think he's just like a a core
Anarchist with like no real strong he
all of his stick is is about some kind
of government program and he would jump
he jumped into the libertarian know but
like outside of his actual character if
you talk to him I know uh decently well
like not I don't hang out with him or
anything but like I've had dinner with
him and talked to him and his thing is
basically like the system is corrupt
these politicians are all corrupt we're
going to mock them ruthlessly and he's
very anarco like strip the government of
its power he's pretty woke that when
when the Mis proba went woke yeah when
the mises guys kind of came in and and
took over the libertarian party uh he is
when he left because he was friendly
with the uh the kind of woke left
leaning Libertarians that were in
positions of power in libertarian is
this is the this is what so many of
these leftists do they or I should say
liberals the moment they
saw actually I'll put it this way they
were never liberals they were never real
anarchists or Libertarians they were
always authoritarian collectivist
crackpots they publicly claimed that
they were anarchist because that was the
popular thing to say I want the
government to not have power over your
life and then once they started
attacking people and gaining power they
were like no we were always for that so
he's the kind of guy who who it it would
seem just marches in lock step with the
with the farle yeah I think I think
personally I think that that he's just
like he'll go wherever he's allowed to
be in the libertarian why was he allowed
to be to dis STIs event I don't know I
found the answer to your question by the
way about the press conference because I
saw the original post it says uh Ronda
santis is about to hold a press
conference outside and uh he's late and
Le like letting the reporters St in the
cold um he said that he'll be back in
New Hampshire on Sunday he wouldn't
answer any questions about what whether
he'll be in the state on Monday or
Tuesday on primary day that's literally
it so he came to a press conference and
said I'll be back see you later and that
was it yeah I'm I I I need to understand
how it is that verman was able to go up
on stage without security doing anything
about it
yeah so nuts I don't know but I because
like we've seen the videos uh Matt Kim
yeah posted a video where he was like I
was just thrown out for no reason they
wouldn't even let him go to the
neighboring building to have dinner I
mean every you know that there's a lot
of personal garbage that's going on with
this stuff it's it's really caddy you
know who's who's saying nice things
about me or mean things about me on
Twitter is is a big uh a big thing for
especially at least you know it seemed
like it was for the disantis campaign if
if if uh you know you interacted with
them and were not uh favorable towards
DeSantis they were they weren't looking
to convince you that you should be
favorable towards DeSantis they were
look convince you that you were a bad
person it's real disappointing cuz
that's like people making fun of the Dan
santis campaign is like trying to light
a spark underneath the campaign to give
it some combustive momentum and they're
like no that burns stop swatting get
that spark out of here it's too hot I'm
really happy that Ron's losing
and well I am because it's like at a
certain point when you were like hey I'm
a big fan I like this guy why don't you
stop doing this bad thing and then
they're like we're going to keep doing
bad thing and I'm like okay and then
they respond with and you know what
you I'm like no that's
exact I'm out see you later guy I had
somebody like complaining that I didn't
cover uh Kim Reynolds endorsement like
months ago I'm like okay it wasn't like
really surprising and then also on the
other hand like you know it was a bigger
deal the that that week that you know
Rick Scott endorsed Trump over Dan
santis the sitting you know senator of
estate and former governor and like they
didn't make a huge deal about that and
then you know
the the the uh personality traits of the
woke are the same as the never trumpers
yeah they're it's the same irrational
anger emotional I should win I should
get what I want principles be damned and
so a lot of these never trumpers latched
on Ronda santis and they dragged him
down to the depths of Destruction and
Oblivion and he's gone and that's it he
is a a sad laughing stock I'm just I'm
imagining someone being like Ron I'm
telling you high heels you're going to
whenn it's going to pull really well I
mean it's uh it sucks that his his um
you know the the people that were
speaking for his campaign weren't uh
weren't a little more proactive in
trying to convince people and be a
little more friendly but at the same
time like Ron was you know he like
talking to a 2x4 listening to 2x4 talk
you know yeah those those videos with
like the painful smiles and like the
robotic movements are just like they're
to they're too much he's an athlete we
needed more of him in action like
physical action you need a leader and
leaders have to be good at a lot of
things so uh when we're looking at
fighting you know Shan Strickland is a
leader we're big fans he's saying some
great stuff he's defending the little
guy and we really respect it he's a good
dude uh he's a wild guy and he's good at
what he does should he be president no
because while he may be the champ when
it comes to his his weight Division and
his fighting when you're a leader you
need a bunch of different
characteristics so Ronda santis let's
say there's 10 categories that make you
a good would make you a good president
Ron maybe has two of them very high
marks and the rest are all in the gutter
so he was not the right choice for this
MH but I am glad he ran because it would
be a disaster for all of us if he didn't
he endorsed Donald Trump trump said
we're going to bring him into the fold
we're big everyone loves Ron and then
come 2027 yeah Ron's running and we're
like what have we done our back bench is
garbage we're in trouble we got nobody
that's true people do credit the Florida
legislature with a lot of what happened
in Florida during the co lock shutdowns
is is keeping that State open was in
part the legislature not and Ron took a
lot of the credit for it but I don't
know who who's going to be the VP man
it's got to be V yeah but even V is not
VP like I mean I think for Success it's
got to be V cuz he's grooming the next
presid they have like the most you know
the most chemistry that we've that we've
seen on stage I mean there hasn't been a
whole lot of you know Trump on stage
with a lot of people and especially
former candidates other gabard maybe I
get that gabard maybe makes sense that's
that's what I'm not I'm not talking the
the idea that V has to be VP because
he's grooming the next president no no
no no that's not what matters what
matters is does the VP help get a new
state am I going to win a state with
this person am I going to win a
demographic with this person and are
they the kind of person that could fit
in a role that is subsidiary and not
very much in the Limelight VI is is is
is is a hot potato man he's not going to
fit in that role Chief of Staff perhaps
something like that I don't even know if
that's the right one he may not want to
work in administration like that I look
I you know would would have preferred V
be the guy to Trump but like I think the
re like he was at you know 8% or
whatever in Iowa he's like 5% or
something like that Nationwide or lower
like I don't see how he how Trump
benefits at all by picking V he doesn't
the country does it's like kind of like
Aaron Rogers like Favre they the Green
Bay drafted Aaron Rogers he sat the
bench for the first year he's a nobody
but they knew he was great and that he
would be great so he Brett Favre you
know just just took you know they all
took it for the team it was about the
team and making the team the best it
could be the thing about him like being
at like 8% uh is I think because he's
aligned so much with Trump that like you
know in the absence of trump I think
that number would be a lot higher
whereas the other candidates that like
they are their support is seen as you
know opposing Trump so it would actually
kind of be confusing to me to like have
him at a higher number because so since
he's so aligned with Trump I feel on a
lot of things that's you know that's
where that's coming from and he's like
actually I think he has some good like
suggestions on you know like Banning the
you know cryptocurrency whatever that
was and then also um you know with the
pardoning of Assange that's another
suggestion uh that like he has told
Trump I guess so you Banning the cbdc
yeah yeah cbdc that's what it was um and
you know the day before he like talked
to him about that he announced that on
the stage and made that part of his
policy so I I feel like someone like who
could give him some more you know advice
on things like that that you know Trump
might not know and help craft policy on
that type of stuff um would be more
beneficial and uh don Jr just had VI on
his show triggered on Rumble two days
ago I think it was two days ago might
have been yesterday it was pretty it was
great to see them together but it was
remote and they were talking over each
other just because of the digital delay
which was you know being in person I
think especially for Don Jr and V who
are like high-powered speakers having
them try and get through it was uh there
was some rough moments but all in all it
looks like they're deep in communication
with the guy I don't know if you need
him to be VP to make him the next
president yeah cuz he could just be a
loud like Tim you saying he's a
loudmouth in a good way he likes to
speak and speak a
lot people are also chatting about
there's like a lot of videos of Ron
eating like like a duck yeah you know
it's like the Simpsons where Frank
Grimes is like eats like a pig like I'd
say eat more like a duck pigs tend to
chew and then it shows Homer like
putting the dut in his mouth like just
like sucking it down it's painful casic
people are posting a bunch of videos
where Ron like we take a sandwich and
just shove half the thing in his mouth
but no I I don't say what the I'm like
the dude's on the Run yeah like he's
he's got he's got to go man I totally
get it you hand me a cheeseburger I'm
going to be like I'm taking that thing
down in two bites they do that stuff I'm
not running for office they do this
stuff all the time it's like when
whenever like every you know cycle or
whatever whoever's running like they get
get bad pictures of him eating the corn
dogs sticking one down the throat I
would lean the Iowa State Fair trap oh
my gosh yeah you got to chew your food
like the only the only the only reason I
would ever really want to run for
president is so that I could just go
nuts on the whole system if you I would
never actually want to I don't want it
all to be in politics but if I feel like
the country needs me or the world needs
me like I feel like it's our duty as
businessmen to go to that level next if
there was ever a point where I could
actually get on the debate stage and
have like a double digit polling but not
win I'd go for it and then it would just
be the funniest thing ever I would like
I would show up to like the iow state
fair and I'd buy like five corn dogs and
just eat them all at one once I would
take five of them and just be like all
right everybody get the photo I just jam
it into my face and be like I take so
little of this seriously like have at it
but the thing is too like it might
actually backfire end up working because
it generates so much press attention
like Trump's first term yeah how he was
just saying all this crazy stuff and
then they were just like run it and then
he ended up winning getting five billion
dollar worth of free marketing there
there is like the argument like there
that that Trump was just trying to like
actually do things that would derail his
campaign that was actually compelling
argument have you heard Michael Moore's
argument what Trump didn't want to be
president yeah he was upset that he
didn't get a better rate on The
Apprentice and it was um what's her face
they paid they paid uh Gwen Stefani or
something he said some woman got paid
more than him he got mad and said why
aren't I getting more for The Apprentice
to the best show and they said because
you're not as big as this person so he's
like okay I'm going to run for
president not going to spend any money
doing it but that's going to raise my
profile and get me a better contract
deal and then he accidentally won and
while I don't believe that for a second
cuz Trump was planning on running for
years cuz he registered Ma and stuff
four years in advance but it was
apparent it is apparently true that when
he did win he was surprised and he was
like in his campaign office on on
Election night he was like I won I
won watching that video think I was
gonna win as the votes are coming in he
like oh man well I mean it's probably
the reality there is that every said
Hillary was going to win she had
everything it Trump was probably like
all right well you know we we shot our
shot right mhm and then he won oh man
talk about good days good days can you
believe that was almost 10 years ago
eight years ago that is actually nuts
years I remember that night that was
nuts oh it was so much fun I'll never
forget it you know like uh like 911 I
will always remember exactly where I was
and how it went down when Donald Trump
won the presidency because it was it was
one of the greatest nights of my life
where were you what were you doing I was
hang out Cassandra uh McDonald at the
Sputnik office where where she had
worked and uh I I was we were we were
hanging out in DC so went up to the
office and I was just sitting there with
my feet up and I was like cool we're
going to I don't know I'm not doing
anything else and Cassandra was like the
only person in the office who was Pro
Trump all the other Sputnik people were
were Democrats and it was funny how
snoody they were being and like smug and
there was like an early report that the
Trump campaign was planning to file like
launching a lawsuit against one of the
states as the results were coming in and
there was one guy was like here he goes
like this is what Trump's going to do
he's going to lose but then we were
watching The New York Times had that
meter and it said like greater than 99%
chance Hillary wins when it starts and
throughout the night it started moving
then it got to 50% and at that point
Cassandra's like tearing up and she's
like oh my god I'm laughing my ass off
and then it got all the way like started
moving down the tears of all the people
in the room as they're crying and then
I'm just sitting there laughing a hearty
laugh and I'm like I didn't vote for the
guy I just thought all of it was crack
crack pottery and then he won and I was
like good this is what you all deserve
you have sat on your hands for so long
and lied to the American people you
voted for Barack Obama and he blew up
kids and now you have the nerve to come
to me and say Hillary Clinton who is
Secretary of State doing all this
garbage deserves to be president you
earned this man and I was just I was
loving it what a good day yeah I was
very much into Bernie and it was
devastating what the DNC did to that
guy's campaign me too I was a big Bernie
fan and uh and they did and so when it
all came crashing down I was another
reason I was laughing is I'm like y'all
you deserve it y'all deserve it the DNC
listen man people wanted burn he had a
lot of Grassroots support he should have
won and when they ripped him off people
just got in line behind Hillary Clinton
and the fact that it failed and blew up
in their faces was so funny to me you
deserve every moment of EV every ounce
of pain every smile Trump makes every
laugh he laughs you deserve every moment
it was funny it was like a gut shot I
don't know if you guys do you remember
the moment you found out when Trump won
that election what were you doing yeah I
was watching it live just like with my
family well well I kind of knew once I
saw Florida like that that was it you
know that that was it that that was the
that was the moment that night where
everyone went wait a minute yeah this
went Trump he's going to win I I just
remember that moment when the New York
Times needle went to the middle and said
50% and then I was like he's going to
win isn't he yeah yeah where were you
doing Phil I was just at my my place in
New Hampshire was it like 3:00 in the
morning or something when the results
came in when they actually called it
called it or well when he gave his
victory speech but I think I think it
was probably around midnight or
something when when it was like
mathematically called on most networks
what a shock you could actually pinpoint
the moment at which Hillary Clinton's
heart was ripped out no I'm kidding
that's a Simpsons joke but she didn't
she didn't give a speech right she just
disappeared I think no she didn't spe
well that's the thing so she didn't have
a concession speech written yeah is why
she didn't give a speech wow she was
probably she she was probably hitting
people screaming like how did this
happen I've heard she was drunk oh she
was hammered I've heard that she she had
she had had a couple drinks before and
then once it started to go really bad
the
drink she never she didn't show up to
her venue she didn't do a concession
speech that night and I heard it was
because she got drunk and was yelling at
people so Putin doesn't drink I don't
know if that matters world leader is
getting trashed makes me nervous we're
going to go to Super Chat so if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to the
channel share the show with your friends
head over to
timcast.net good name shout out to the
timcast members who helped come up with
it and sleepy Joe there's also unwoke
but I think sleepy Joe is way better
yeah yeah yeah you can drink it before
bed all right let's grab some super
chats and YouTube's giving me the
business for some reason but I'll do my
best
jerks let's see Josh a beim says fourth
in fact sir you were you were first but
because you called it wrong we're not
going to count it we're going to give
the first mission to barely a millennial
no I'm just kidding you're first barely
a millennial says we had to put our
American esimo dog Nina down today the
best part of being a kid is not having
to do the hard things that sucks sorry
here you're here rest in
peace all right Kane abble says hey Tim
did you ever find out about that Texas
Ranger versus fed thing or have any
updates on that I wonder if that would
be the new start of the next civil war
history often Rhymes the reason why I
did bring it up I didn't want I haven't
tweeted about it or anything is because
if we can't verify who the person is and
and and if the husband's in law
enforcement can't get a statement on the
record we don't want to that being said
an individual called into a public show
to thousands of people and said this is
a thing that is happening that much I
think we will repeat and then I will
clarify we do not have any confirmation
outside of this uh however there are
other individuals who are retired Texas
Troopers that probably have connections
and it sounds rather reasonable that
this is happening if you are working in
law enforcement in Texas and you're
being ordered to defy the federal
government to their faces with guns you
may be concerned sooner or later fed's
going to try to stop you we'll
see all right maniple says second of all
wait was there second of all where will
the new North Poles be guys go to tenet
media on YouTube subscribe watch the
culture War podcast it is Fridays at 10:
a.m. live we put up Clips on youtube.com
timcast but we all redirect you over to
our friends at tenant media it's a great
little super group we got going on and
the show this morning was about a poll
shift which may be occurring I don't
know I'm not a scientist but uh the
argument
is that periodically throughout it's
every 12,000 years or whatever the polls
shift this is a fact what here's here's
a really interesting fact from the show
runways are being renamed because of the
the the pole shift we name runways based
off their position on on the with the
compass or whatever on the Earth but now
that the polls are shifting it's
changing the names of these runways
because if you're flying using your
instruments to find Runway with this
name if the name stayed the same the r
the compass would point in the wrong
direction and so it's like but that's
actually happening that's a fact you can
find that on like the US Government
website where they're like hey we have
to the pole shift is happening rather
rapidly and so the idea is that the
Earth will tilt and as it does it
wobbles moves down and then starts
correcting the spin will stay the same
but the axis rotation and I guess the
argument is the poles are heavy right
now and so that'll cause it to wobble
and then spin but then correct itself
and start spinning again and I guess
that would put Antarctica at the Equator
so it'll be the East and West pole no
the polls will be North and South okay
but Antarctica will be on the on the
equator and that would put uh Florida on
the South
Pole I guess is the argument yeah I mean
it makes sense that that would happen
you know I mean I don't know about how
fast it happens and I don't know what
would you know he said he was saying
like a week oh that would probably be
like a matter of a day or or so it
happens rapidly that you'll be in
Florida and you'll be like oh sunset's
at 7:30 and then Sunset happens and then
the Sun never comes up because the Earth
tilted and now you're in the Antarctic
Circle yeah awful you're like I'm cold
now what's happening so one of the
things he he pointed out is that we
found wly mammoths Frozen with food
still in their bellies meaning they were
flash frozen they were frozen nearly
instantly and so he's he was pointing
out like or he was asking what could
cause a woly mammoth to freeze so
quickly that its food would be intact in
its belly more of the point where did
the food come from if the woly mammoths
were in this Arctic region or whatever
or or you know minus5 how were their
vegetables around for it to eat what was
it eating if its stomach is full of
vegetation yeah the hypothesis is that
it was in the equatorial area and it
there was plenty of vegetation and then
that whole area flipped up North and
then that's where they were right and so
well this is what he's arguing I'm not a
scientist I don't know but he's arguing
that they're basically at the equator
eating veggies within a day the Earth
flips and all of a sudden they're in the
Arctic Circle all the plant life is dead
and it's minus5 instantly and they just
freeze they freeze to death almost
instantly nowhere to go nowhere to stay
warm and there's no food and they just
Frozen and that could happen now that's
what he's arguing watch the show it was
such a good show yeah watch the show
yeah it was actually the largest live
audience we've had on on tenant media
nice a not for the culture War but for
the for tenant YouTube channel nice the
com a lot of comments are like this is
the best one ever I sometimes I'll see
those comments on certain shows but it's
nice to see that comment over and over
on that episode it was great dude Ben
Davidson and Jimmy corsetti Superstars
wild show all right nikosia connection
says Tim please have venu Vargis on he's
an attorney in New York City on the
front lines his recent case is
representing Dexter Taylor who dared
exercise a Second Amendment right in New
York City and 3D printed Firearms the
culture is on even in New York City
great to work great work to everyone at
timcast that would be a good guy to have
on the uh culture War show culture War
show is a better show for when we're
doing one-on-one stories like that and
IRL is better when we're doing news
commentary so there are a lot of people
who will reach out and be like I'd love
to come on your show and I'm like we'll
we'll get someone who's a scientist and
wants to come on timcast IRL but I'm
like we're not an interview podcast like
Joe Rogan we're a we're a news
commentary show so we're looking for
cultural and political junkies but uh
that's why we decided to launch the
culture War show which you should should
subscribe
to all right all right let's grab some
more Super chats JK says great culture
War podcast earlier thank you been
watching both those guys as long as you
you need to let all that expand yeah uh
the fascinating thing about uh Ben he's
not
like it it he's not coming out and
saying aliens and other crazy nonsense
he was saying things like well one of
the I asked him if the polls shifted and
Antarctica is at the equator will it
melt and he says not necessarily because
we have tropical glaciers right now that
haven't melted they've been there for
thousands of years and I went wait a
minute what I didn't know that yes H
tropical glaciers in like Indonesia for
instance that are high altitude they
don't melt exactly so they've been there
for a very long time and I'm like
interesting so Antarctica could move to
the equator there would be Coastal
melting but L the large ice formations
May remain how high is the highest
mountain in Antarctica you know or
highest peak I don't know you probably I
was G say it' be like a huge land grab
for if if it suddenly just became that
way I mean a lot would change but all of
Antarctica would be would be like land
no it I I you know part of me thinks it
would be the coolest thing ever if
Antarctica was at the equator and just
started melting and there's a new
frontier yeah exactly but only if after
the ice melted there was like an
abandoned city oh wow and we were like
when all this ice melted we found
Atlantis I was going to say Atlantis the
highest point of Antartica called M
Vincent it's 16,000 ft High that's not
much that's not super high that's like
Utah road Les traveled says if you're
planning on going to the Republican
National Convention in Milwaukee or just
a fan of History look up Road l traveled
Wisconsin for information about the
little white Schoolhouse in Ripon
Wisconsin the birthplace of the
Republican party ah very
interesting yeah we are planning to be
there for the RNC we've got uh we got
some good plans coming some good plans
for the RN and
see all right Greg Cutler says Ian I
threw down $100 last year to just to
shout out Ben Davidson and the
suspicious observers glad to hear you
got together I'll definitely watch it
dude people keep telling me you gotta
get in touch with Ben with Ben Davidson
you got to get in touch with Ben
Davidson because I've been talking a lot
about the electric Universe the dude we
were talking about that during these
pole shifts and these geomagnetic phases
that the moon can get pulled towards the
Earth really fast and then pushed away
and the amount of like to like just
torrential uh flooding and and like cuz
the moon sucks the waves it'll like make
the waves get really tall when the
moon's closer to the Earth the
catastrophe the guy's just absolutely
awesome I had no idea suspicious
observers was as big as it is uh I have
only been following him on Twitter so
it's really really great to see M says
if the New York Times paper was to
finally collapse would we be happy or
celebrate its end just says people are
celebrating the end of Sports
Illustrated I'm torn right but but it's
like because it's been taken over by
Communists we want it to be destroyed
that's kind of a scary thought what if
we took it over and made it run by like
capitalists and pro americ people I like
that the part of me likes the fact that
the you know that the progressives have
uh a place where they test out their
ideas and like that's kind of what I
look at like the Atlantic and New York
Times like they the go to the op EDS
yeah go to the op EDS and you all the
Terrible ideas the left has they're
they're they're telegraphing all of them
go ahead no no finish well these these
ideas that they that they test in the
opinion Pages these are what will
eventually turn into policy you know
that's where the ideas come from what if
tomorrow the front page of the New York
Times was all American flag backdrop and
the Articles were all about the history
of Communism and why communism is bad I
would subscribe that' be great I would I
would subscribe for a year and I would
deal with whatever they wanted to put
out after that I would deal with it yeah
true they that New York
Times they'll never do it they were they
were white they were redw washing the
Soviet Union while stallin was killing
people yeah true like they yeah they
they were they're they're sympathetic
yeah the whole like the whole
Progressive project the whole first half
of the last century people were lying
for the Soviet Union cuz all the all the
intelligency all the academics thought
that socialism was the future they
thought it was a great idea and they all
wanted the Soviet Union to actually work
out and so they're all just lying for
him the New York Times They had horrible
people that we're just covering for
Stalin it's awful J W Dickson says I
hope this is seen you need to make a K
cup coffee pod sampler so people don't
have to buy a full pack to find out if
they like or hate it good point that's a
great idea here's a funny one the real
Hydro PX says you said this yesterday
are you an NPC Tim do you just say
things to look cool and be right or
you're in security Hydro what you need
to understand is as one of our biggest
fans who watches every single single
episode yeah literally we know that the
average person watches three episodes
per month that's the average person and
so that means somewhere around 60% of
the individuals who watch timcast IRL
don't hear and don't watch consecutive
episodes so if I'm going to be talking
about a subject and I ignore the core
point of the subject assuming someone's
heard it the chat will be flooded with
what are you talking about so we have to
operate on a light of assumption that
the average person at any given moment
on a show has not watched the show the
previous day yeah it's similar to if
you're talking about someone we all know
and we're using first name basis we got
to use their last name when we're on TV
it's just a something you got to be a
little different when you have the
cameras on and you're this broadcasting
I I'll give I'll give you one example of
how it's difficult to navigate esoteric
subjects the what we say on this show on
a daily basis is an esoteric subject you
don't know the subject of what we talked
about unless you watch every episode
when we had VI ramaswami on and we asked
him about Central Bank digital currency
he did what many people do when
discussing this the subject is so
complicated that instead of saying
here's what blockchain is here's what
Bitcoin is here's what cryptocurrencies
are Central Bank instead of that he goes
the problem with cbdc right away is that
you've got a government and I'm like
wait wait stop what is cbdc oh oh
Central Bank digital currencies anyway
the point is no no no no stop what does
that mean and so he he says I'm going to
get to that and then he starts talking
about blockchain and I'm like listen
people don't know what blockchain is
I've I deal with this all the time it's
not but what happens is someone who
knows and pays attention to every show
knows that c what cbdc is so someone
will come on this show as a guest and
they'll say well I'm hoping Donald Trump
calls out cbdc because we had a big
problem and then 80% of viewers go I
have no idea what he's talking about
I've noticed that on shows sometimes
there's the experts two experts talking
at each other and I just want to listen
to them experts speak even if I don't
understand the words I'm like I'll
figure it out later Go full expert nerd
don't assume don't don't dumb it down
just go full expert but then other times
I'm like I want to watch more of a show
which explains to the general audience
like labels what they mean and I just I
kind of go back and forth there's
different uh types of shows in that
sense so you need to say something like
blockchain is a digital Ledger a book
containing a list of actions made by
people who are exchanging something of
value the digital currencies are
essentially things you can have on the
internet that represent value really
simple the government wants to create
their own version that they would
control that would be a bad thing
because it gives them technological
access to all currencies they can spy on
you much more easily they can control
what you buy much more easily they can
ban you from stores or even from regions
right now they can do these things
through difficult uh measures with the
Federal federal government court systems
freezing your bank accounts but with
Central Bank digital currency one day
you can get a notification that you are
not allowed to buy things within 50
miles of Austin Texas and they can
easily control that if with a
cbdc less it's less easy with uh The
Current financial system but social
credit scores all that stuff it opens
the door if they make that move so uh we
say no
yeah all right scrot Johnson says funny
thing is Porsche is owned by VW but vw's
holding company is Porsche literally a
loop yep that's so crazy very
weird limited liability schemes yeah is
like that's like corruption staring Us
in the face kind of behavior Tesla hack
says on the topic of the casino and no
one in charge this Ian isn't correct
decentralization also decentralizes
responsibility a web of interconnected
systems is hard to hold accountable
unlike a singular leader that's a great
point and that is the point I was
dealing with if you're so if you're
having a problem in one of these big
casinos and there's no general manager
that's it have a nice day like there's
nothing you can do so when I had an
issue where I a guy threatened to to so
what happened was I was in the poker
room at Hollywood Charlestown and they
apologized to me relentlessly over this
but uh I will use the poker terminology
for everybody and if you don't
understand stand too bad I did what's
called an ace high hero call all uh on
on an all-in basically we're playing
poker I'll simplify the guy is making
big bets I don't believe he's I don't
believe he's actually got a hand I I I
think he's got garbage so I call his
bets in the end he pushes all of his
money into the middle basically saying
my hand is so good I'm putting up
$300 you have to have $300 to call me
out and I said I call I throw the money
in and then I flip over Ace King off
suit not the best hand but a pretty good
hand and he is this all pre flop no this
is the this is the river this is the end
he bluffed all the way down he looks at
what I have and he just has this look of
shock and then he throws his cards into
the muck meaning he just gets rid of him
and then they shove all the money to me
meaning I called him out he was
surprised I called him out he got really
angry came back half an hour later and
started threatening to hit me and beat
me up and smack me and insulting me and
that's that's a that's a no-o any casino
in any poker room instant perab ban you
go to any major casino and so I was like
can I get the floor over here like holy
crap they didn't I asked for the floor
several times finally I got up and I'm
like yo what the went to the went to the
guy who runs it and I said this guy's
threatening to attack me can I get
security or like what's going on here
man he he basically came over and said
chill out shut up and play the game so I
said okay I want to speak to his in
charge there was no one in charge no one
runs the show no one's in charge of
security issues security guards came
over and said I don't know what happened
and I'm like can you guys like watch the
cameras and see him threatening to hit
me and all stuff and they're like I
don't know and I was like is there a
boss or a manager of the casinos in
charge no each individual space has
their own authority and jurisdiction so
if the guy who runs the poker room says
don't know don't care didn't see it the
security guy says I'm I don't work for
him he doesn't work for me there's no
other general managers it only got
resolved like seven months later when a
guy who watches the show and worked in
the food department as a manager
asked me like uh so they they had an
there was a republican event using the
casino conference space and he was there
and he was like yeah here you're a big
fan you play poker I was like not here
anymore not since that guy threatened to
attack me and you guys did nothing he
went what I get a phone call right away
from the Casino Host apologizing saying
they'll they'll they'll fix it and I
said fine fine uh I once again
boycotting them however because they
stole $40 for me wait the so the Casino
Host is like the top dog over there he's
a customer relations guy who wants to
convince people to play the game so
there's no boss that's got to not be
true I feel like they just lied to you
yeah that's bizarre yeah I I there's
there's no
boss that's son there's an come come on
who who who do you call when you have a
problem on Facebook who's the manager
you speak to at Facebook when you get
banned there's nobody yeah there's none
so the whole system is decentralized
there of course is someone who's in
charge of the casino at perhaps like a
regional level but they're not in the
building and they're not there and
there's no fun you can't talk to them so
the only way you get anything resolved
is first this one's really important if
you guys are ever having problems with a
major company and they're you
around be
rich okay now after you're rich it also
helps to have 2 million followers on
Twitter okay followers okay now that
we've gotten through that followers
these companies will finally apologize
to you and this is the worst thing about
our modern corporatist system is that
the only way to actually be treated
fairly by these faceless gigantic
disgusting machines is if you can wield
influence against them and it's sad
it is pathetic that you would have to do
something like that but you know what I
suppose that's it let them feel all the
pain of treating their customized like
garbage because sooner or later they
treat the wrong person like garbage and
and then they have to deal with that
that's why I'm drawn to mob rule because
like I noticed that in 2006 with
internet video like the amount of people
I could amass to make a phone call to
one person at a a certain time I was
like yo I can command the masses with
this technology real easy and I wanted
to but I I I also realized how dangerous
that could be and that I'm corruptible
and I was like I got to just build
systems that let people organize I can't
I can't try and be some cult leader
pushing I mean but then the argument is
like if you're up against corporations
that are screwing the little guy maybe
you do need a cult leader to step up and
command the forces the people to go make
calls and to show up here and say this
and all that I'm going to take this
Friday opportunity to uh winge a little
bit and on this point so I was at uh
Maryland Live which which is at
Arendelle Hills Arendelle Mills big mall
shopping mall and they have a casino and
this place knows customer service so we
there was a there was a a dispute we had
over a bet on a table the per the the
the supervisor on the floor was arguing
with us I was getting I was getting
perturbed like not angry but I was like
look we're trying to do this this is
what we did you can't push our bet back
blah blah blah then finally I went okay
don't worry about it make the bet no
point in arguing thank you for your for
patronage and I was like oh that was
very nice of them at the same at the
same place I was playing SBO which is uh
three die roll you make a b with it it's
going to be a very simple game and I
accidentally put more than the max down
and I lost and they went sir you bet too
much and they gave me half my bet
back Hollywood Casino pen
entertainment it's like the gutter of
casinos we were putting down so this is
why we're currently boycotting them and
this is this might be the final straw we
were putting money down on craps
it was Allison's turn to roll the die
there were only three people at the
table as she's putting the money down
they hand the die to the wrong guy and
he throws them and the die hit the wall
we're like whoa whoa whoa no roll no
roll like we're still betting and like
what they're like nope your money's ours
and they pull our money and I was like
whoa dude stop you're out of turn the
wrong person
threw no Dead
Roll they said no if you don't like it
you can leave and then I said if my $40
is worth that much to you I'll never
come back to casino and they said it
absolutely is your right to say that and
I was like okay have fun so don't go to
that place don't go to pen entertainment
yeah runs these things uh and and I also
say this too look at look at what
happened with Porto they booted barol
Sports Penn bought bar stool sold it
back to poroy for a dollar he made like
half a billion dollars on that deal best
deal in like the the 21st century so far
no for real so poroy sells bar stool
Sports to pen entertainment for half a
billion I think was half a billion and
then not even a year later or whatever
they're like we're going to give you the
whole thing back for a dollar why be-
because it is the like dude but also
isn't that like fraud for that's just
like PTO getting free money yes but
that's got to be like fraud they they so
apparently what was happening was David
poroy has no problem calling people out
he disagrees with there was an issue
where mincy cool dude by the way was
rapping on a show and said the nword in
a rap they fired him poroy was like
that's BS I was pissed I'm like come on
dude min's a good guy he was just
rapping a song they fired him Dave is a
good dude gave miny a job at his watch
company he had his back I tremendously
respect that bar stool was freaking out
because they were like we are going to
get denied gaming licenses in States
because of hate speech and things like
that so bar stool was too edgy so so I I
don't know exactly what happened what I
imagine is they went to Dave and said
will you buy back bar stol he's like no
and they were like we are losing gaming
licenses over this we have we can't have
the brand attached to us anymore and he
was like too bad you bought it and they
were like will you buy it back for this
right no will you buy it back for this
no can we give it to you okay that's
probably what happened I don't know for
sure but he bought it back for $1 he got
all the money he owns the company he
hired meny back Bravo dude pen
entertainment Hollywood casinos are the
worst run establishments I have ever
been to so anyway uh we're going to
we're going to we're going to go uh
we're going to go playing the snow
there's there's a crap ton of snow out
there we're going to go snowboarding
awful it's it's terrible the roads are
shut down there a state of emergency but
my friend smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends head over to
timcast.net goes to putting up
Billboards buying commercials of Alex
Stein we did $25,000 in a commercial of
Alex Stein trying to free base coffee
that's kind of so you might be thinking
wow that's the stupidest thing I ever
heard I better not give this guy money
then don't awesome right but if you like
that we're doing those things that's
what your membership gets we also it
enables us to do these on the ground
shows we're doing more Live Events this
year and so that and then we hire more
people we're producing music we're
building culture we've got documentaries
and shows so uh support our work if you
like it you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me personally
at timcast Alx do you want to shout
anything out Alx on
x.com simple enough I am Phil that
remains on Twix I'm Phil that remains
official on Instagram the band is All
That Remains you can follow us on
Spotify Apple music Pandora YouTube
Amazon you know oh wait you know and one
more thing don't forget the left lane is
for Crime for crying crime you know you
know that saying they say be gay do
crime yeah the opposite of that is don't
be gay don't do crime yeah but I think
that and and I think that generally you
shouldn't be gay or do crime if well I
mean you can be gay if you're gay but
that's the point right like I feel like
they've made this phrase intentionally
so that the inverse of it is something
that we mostly wouldn't be agree we
wouldn't agree with because like the
more liberal moderate person would be
like well you know I can understand why
someone wouldn't want their kid to be
gay they would have grandkids but we're
fairly libertarian just don't do crime
it's not a very strong rebuttal it's not
but especially like someone's going to
bring up the left lane and then I'm just
Pro crime in the left left lane talking
about driving in the left we got we got
all right everybody have a beautiful
evening I'm Ian cross great week we'll
see you again next week let's do this
again and definitely check out that
culture War episode from today awesome
Roger Stone on Monday pumped I haven't
met him yet so I'm really looking
forward to putting these puzzle pieces
together all about election good to see
Alex as always man good to see sge Yo
Alx pleasure man uh as always good to
actually talk to you this time uh yeah
I'm excited for the weekend and for
dealing with the snow in the rest of
this uh this storm that's going to be
happening uh let's just uh go home all
right everybody we will see you all on
Monday thanks for hanging
out
I